la politique Sénet demain à 18h30 sur
Public
Sénat bonjour vous allez pouvoir suivre
dans un instant la proposition de loi
socialiste sur les réseaux de soins
mutualiste un texte qui provoque une
levée de bouclier chez certains
professionnels de santé cette loi on est
faet autorise les mutuels à mieux
rembourser ce qui s'adresse à des
professionnels référencés dans leur
réseau de soins en clair seront moins
bien remboursés les spécialistes qui
pratiquent des dépassements d'honoraires
importants alors ces médecins comptent
sur l'opposition sénatoriale pour livr
bataille contre ce texte pour les
rassurer les sénateurs ont voté en
commission un amendement qui définit
strictement les domaines dans lesquels
les complémentaires pourront moduler ses
remboursements en clair
cela ne toucherait ni les opticiens ni
les dentistes voilà tout de suite
direction
l'hémicycle légitimité pour être des
acteurs à part entière et agir dans le
domaine des réseaux de soins avec des
effets positifs que l'on relève
l'objectif des réseaux de soins de faire
pression sur les prix pour diminuer le
reste à charge pour dans les patients
pour les patients dans un contexte où 10
à 15 % de nos concitoyens disent avoir
renoncé à des soins et par parulrement
dans les secteurs cités pour des raisons
financières la réduction du reste à
charge pour le patient doit être le fil
conducteur de nos orientations en
matière de protection sociale et tout ce
qui peut y participer doit être
encouragé la proposition de loi que nous
présentons aujourd'hui a été enrichi par
notre assemblée par répondre aux
craintes que nous avons entendu en
précisant les grands principes qui le la
soutendent et garantissent la régulation
et la transparence de ces réseaux ainsi
l'article 2 nouveau précise le cadre
juridique des réseaux de soins quel que
soit leur statut il précise que les
conventions conclus ne peuvent porter
sur le niveau des tarifs pratiqués par
le médecin pour les actes et prestations
qui sont remboursé par l'assurance
maladie obligatoire dans le cadre des
conventions médicales nationales il
interdit les clauses d'exclusivité et
indique que le réseau ne peut porter
atteintre lib choix du patient qu'il
doit reposer sur des critères objectifs
transparents et non discriminatoire de
sélection des professionnels madame la
ministre en insistant l' rappelé il
garantit une information claire et
complète des adhérents sur les
caractéristiques des soins mis en place
par sa complémentaire ainsi que sur
l'impact sur les garanties souscrites le
patient pourra donc choisir en toute
connaissance de cause choisir son
pratricien et connaître le montant de
son
remboursement l'article 3 nous nouveau
prévoit qu'à compté du 30 juin 2013 un
rapport annuel adressé au Parlement par
le gouvernement analysera les
conséquence de la mise en place des
réseaux de soins quant à la qualité des
prestations offertes et à l'amélioration
de l'accès aux soins des assurés
concernés afin d'aller encore plus loin
la commission des affaires sociales de
notre Assemblée a adopté plusieurs
amendements du rapporteur ainsi il nous
a proposé la possibilité pour les
organismes complémentaires de
contractualiser avec des professions de
santé sans que les conventions
comportent de clauses tarifaires hormis
pour les chirurgiens dentistes les
opticiens et surt prothésistes les
conventions avec les médecins ne
pourront pas avoir pour effet une
modulation du remboursement et les
conventions entre les mutuels et les
professionnels ne pourront pas entraîner
de discrimination dans la délivrance des
soins enfin les réseaux de soins seront
ouverts à tous les professionnels
remplissant les conditions fixées sauf
pour l'ortique ou la
démographie justifie le recours de cet
outil de régularisation en effet dans ce
secteur on observe une forte croissance
des magasins d'optique avec 47 % de
points de vente de plus par rapport à
2000 croissance qui excède largement
l'augmentation des besoins médicaux de
la population et entraîn une
sous-productivité qui se traduit dans
les marges brutes prélevé par les
opticiens cet article avec une précision
qui sera apportée par le reporteur
tendra a également affirmé qu'être dans
un réseau de soins ne revient pas à être
favorisé pour l'accès aux soins ainsi le
notre groupe dans sa majorité votera ce
texte qui tout en donnant une base
juridique à des réseaux existant et
opérant ce qui est son objectif
principal à court terme disspe les
inquiétudes qu'il a suscité
particulièrement c'est le concernant
l'inclusion des médecins dans le
dispositifs l'aliénation du choix des
patients et et la crainte d'une moindre
qualité des prestations la grande loi
santé publique à laquelle nous
travaillons viendra en son temps
répondre à tous les enjeux majeurs pour
l'organisation de notre système de santé
elle nous permettra de débattre sur le
sujet global de la régulation de l'offre
de soins dans notre pays pour que les
générations à à venir continuent à
bénéficier d'une protection sociale
juste et solidaire et d'un accès aux
soins qui ne sont pas régis seulement
par une logique du
marché merci madame la
sénatrice la parole est à Madame
Catherine Génisson pour le groupe
socialiste pour 6
minutes monsieur monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre madame la Présidente
de commission monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues en 2012 le président de
la République dans discours devant le
Congrès de la Mutualité Française a
rappelé avec force la place des mutuels
de notre système de protection
sociale dans son intervention il avait
fait une analyse très approfondie de
notre système de protection sociale et
de notre système de santé avec un seul
objectif garantir un égal accès à des
soins de qualité pour l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens c'est dans ce cadre qu'il
avait pris l'engagement de permettre
mutuel la mise en place de réseau de
soins tels que définis dans la propos de
loi que nous examinons quand aujourd'hui
les mutuels vivent une inégalité de
situation par rapport aux assurances
complémentaires et au caisses de
prévoyan c'est dans cet esprit
d'approche globale de notre système de
protection sociale que nous devrions
aborder l'examen de ce
texte merci à notre rapporteur de son
analyse approfondie du fonctionnement de
notre système de protection sociale qui
met en évidence l'importance du système
complémentaire 26 milliards d'euros au
regard des 138 milliards de financement
public soit 13,7 % des dépenses de santé
quand les Muel il participe à un taux de
55 %. merci à lui de nous avoir rappelé
que trois secteurs très différents
connaissent deux points communs des prix
libres des remboursements de l'assurance
maladie très minoritaire les soins
dentaires l'udioprothèse et l'optique en
rappelant sur ce dernier sujet
l'intervention symbolique de l'assurance
maladie à un taux d'environ 4 % au
regard des 45 % des systèmes
complémentaires nous ne pouvons nous
satisfaire de ce constat et il n'y a pas
de fatalité à ce qu'il
perdure loin de moi la volonté de faire
preuve d'angélisme ba aussi je ne
réclame pas aujourd'hui au regard du
déficit de l'assurance maladie de
contributions supplémentaires même si le
sujet reste d'actualité mais je
considère indispensable que l'assurance
maladie participe activement au débat
des conditions d'existence des réseaux
les sujets d'exigigen de qualité au
meilleur prix les conditions
d'accessibilité au meilleurs soins quel
que soit le territoire les procédures de
traçabilité d'évaluation des dispositifs
médicaux proposés
l'information la responsabilisation de
nos concitoyens sont des sujets
essentiels l'assurance maladie s
peremptoire dans son ordonnance
d'économie pour réduire son déficit
j'évoque entre autres ces préconisations
concernant la prise en charge des
pathologies thyroïdiennes des cancers de
la thyroïde ne peut s'exonérer de ses
responsabilités quand par exemple de 0 à
20 ans 30 % de nos jeunes ont des
problèmes de vision et portent des
lunettes merci au complémentaires merci
au mutuel d'avoir pris la responsabilité
de s'investir avec compétence dans ce
débat au combien fondamental les
complémentaires ont mis en place des
réseaux de soins et de fait se sont
autorégulés loin de moi l'idée de leur
enfer grief leur rôle est essentiel mais
je pense que les pouvoirs publics
doivent participer à l'évaluation
qualitative des dispositifs proposés et
doivent être vigilants à la façon dont
les conventions sont traitées entre les
usagers et les organismes
complémentaires nous avons d'ailleurs eu
ce débat ce matin en commission et je
pense que nous le
reprendrons monsieur le rapporteur vous
avez fait un travail considérable en
réécrivant les articles 1 et 2 de la
proposition de loi en particulier en
mettant l'ensemble des complémentaires à
même niveau de droit et des devoirs vous
avez largement amélioré le concept de
réseau de soin pour autant le débat
reste ouvert quand vous inscrivez dans
le texte la possibilité d'existence de
réseau fermés pour l'optique argant
d'une offre conséquente qui mérite
régulation c'est une réalité qui
cependant
trouve comment dire heur pardon
l'exigence de traitement égalit pour nos
concitoyens qu'on sont mis en place des
tarifs différenciés de remboursement
même si le libre choix des citoyens est
clairement acté personnellement je ne
suis pas favorable à ces réseaux ouverts
fermés pardon et j'ai pu constater qu'au
sein même de la Mutualité française il y
avait des avis divergents sur le sur ce
projet en soulignant par ailleurs la
chaleur la qualité et la sincérité des
relations que j'ai pu entretenir avec
les différents acteurs de la mutualité
et vous pouvez imaginer qu'ils ont ét
nombreux je pense que s'il y a
surabondance de d'offre en matière
d'optique ce loit d'ê doit être traité
en amont entre autres au niveau des
lieux de formation avec la possibilité
par exemple de proposer des formations
complémentair aux étudiants que la
démographie médicale des opthalmologues
est un problème dans beaucoup de nos
territoires madame la ministre nous
connaissons votre énergie votre
compétence et votre détermination et
aujourd'hui vous travaillez sur beaucoup
de sujets mais entre autres sur
l'évolution des contrats solidaires et
responsables notre débat aurait pu
s'inscrire dans ce cadre et malgré le
travail très conséquent effectué par
notre rapporteur je regrette l'approche
encore trop contrainte que cette
proposition de loi donne de
l'organisation des réseaux de soins
aussi je ne je ne participerai pas au
vote de cette proposition de loi
merci
la parole est à Monsieur René telade
pour le groupe socialiste pour 6
minutes monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers
collègues en matière de
santé le renoncement aux soins est un
phénomène de plus en plus préignant et
pour preuve en 2010
32,6 % des personnes qui n'était pas
couverte par une
complémentaire déclaré avoir renoncé à
des soins pour raisons
pécunières dès lors il n'est pas
surprenant de constater que dans le
cadre de la Conférence nationale contre
la pauvreté et l'inclusion sociale qui
s'est tenu l'hiver dernier le groupe de
travail sur la santé la accès au soins
préconisé une extension de la couverture
maladie universelle de la CMU
complémentaire ainsi qu'un accès au
complémentairire santé à des coûts
maîtrisés pour les plus démunis par
conséquent la fragilisation et la
paupérisation croissante d'une frange
importante de la population font de
l'accès aux soins une vive problématique
qui se posle qui se pose à l'échelle
même du continent européen et en guise
d'illustration comment ne pas mentionner
la Grèce où le tribu de la crise
économico-sociale a résulté en une
résurgence de maladie pensée depuis
longtemps qui quas était disparu bien
évidemment toute comparaison abusive
nous ferait tomber dans
l'inanité notre système de santé n'a pas
été autant affecté que celui de l'État
hélénique par les politiques
d'assainissement budgétaire pour autant
d'autres funestes fléau tels que la
désertification médicale participe au
creusement des inégalités territoriales
et renforce les difficultés d'accès au
soin or l'intérêt de la présente
proposition de loi réside
précisément dans l'apport d'une solution
à ses entraves permettre au mutuel
d'améliorer l'accès aux soins de leurs
affiliés en régulant les secteurs
inflationnistes ou ceux délaissés par
l'Assurance Maladie c'est-à-dire les
secteurs où elles sont légitimes pour
intervenir aujourd'hui la part des
remboursements des complémentaires santé
et majoritaire en matière d'optique de
soins dentaires et d'audioprothèse à
titre d'exemple en moyenne l'assurance
maladie rembourse 4 % des frais
d'équipement en optique quand les
organismes complémentaires prennent en
charge 45 % de la dépense autrement dit
il demeure un reste à charge
singulièrement élevée pour le patient
qui explique d'ailleurs dans une large
mesure le renoncement aux soins que
j'évoqué précédemment sans revenir
exhaustivement sur les dispositions du
texte parfaitement présenté d'ailleurs
par le
rapporteur la pratique du remboursement
différencié en du recours à un
professionnel de santé
conventionné selon les conditions
strictes fixées par la proposition de
loi est de nature à diminuer le reste à
charge des adhérents et donc d'améliorer
leur accès aux soins par ailleurs ai-je
bien entendu et saisi les arguments des
profondeurs de la modulation du
remboursement sur le fondement du
conventionnement mutualiste la liberté
de choix du praticien par le patient
seraitentravé en réalité il s'agit là
d'un postulat spécieux l'incitation
financière visant à faire appel à un
professionnel de santé membre d'un
réseau de soins n'est en aucun cas une
obligation la nuance est donc de taille
et il faudra veiller à ce que la
couverture territoriale du réseau soit
bien entendu la meilleure possible
d'autre part il a été mis en exerg que
la qualité des équipements fournis
serait de moins bonnes factur dans les
réseaux de soins en l'espèce la
constitution de tel réseau n'aurait
aucun sens si elle aboutissait à une
détérioration de la dite qualité au
contraire il semble que l'encadrement
des appels d'offre afférant à la
procédure d'adhésion aux convention
ainsi que le contrôle exercé par les
mutuels sur les professionnels de santé
membres des réseaux favorise un accès
aux soins de haute qualité à un coût
raisonnable comme en témoigne d'ailleurs
plusieurs études enfin conformément à
l'engagement du président de la
République retranscrit au sein de la loi
relative à la sécurisation de l'emploi
après accord de la majorité des
partenaires sociaux la généralisation de
la couverture complémentaire santé
obligatoire d'ici 2017 doit être salué
néanmoins je tiens hardardemment elle a
souligné qu'elle n'est qu'un premier pas
en effet l'amélioration de l'accès au
sohait ne peut s'arrêter au seul
salariés les étudiants les chômeurs les
retraités ne doivent pas être oubliés
car à terme le risque est d'assister à
l'avèement d'un système à trois vitesses
où l'assurance maladie serait complétée
par une couverture complémentaire qui ne
serait obligatoire que pour certains
tandis que les plus aisés prendrai une
surcomplémentaire
Infiné serait une nette régression par
rapport au modèle pensé après la guerre
enjeu éminent de santé publique mais
plus substantiellement révélateur du
progrès social au sein de notre société
l'amélioration de l'accès aux soins où
le refus de l'inégalité devant la
souffrance doit rester un late motif
permanent c'est la raison pour laquelle
personnellement j'ai souvent défini la
sécurité sociale comme le droit à ne pas
courber les chines euh je n'ai pas
toujours été compris et j'explique alors
que c'est en corise lors de ma jeunesse
que j'avais vu deux pauvres voisins se
courber jusqu'à terre après la visite
gratuite de leur médecins afin de le
remercier de ne pas payer et d'avoir
même participé à l'achat des médicaments
en laissant sur la table de nuit une
certaine somme je dirais nous devons
l'affirmer en permanence et c'est là le
fond de notre débat futur la sécurité
sociale et ce qui sépare la charité du
droit et la dignité de l'assistance je
vous
remercie merci mon cher collègue
dernière oratrice madame Patricia
chilinget pour le groupe socialiste pour
minutes
il faut me mettre
àur monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègues en 2008
15,4 % de la population adulte déclaré
avoir renoncé à des soins médicaux pour
des raisons financières au cours des 12
derniers mois ces renoncements
concernent en premier lieu les soins
dentaires et optiques pour lesquels de
la part des dépenses remboursées par
l'assurance maladie obligatoire est plus
faible 4 % pour les dépenses d'optique
et complémentairire santé en prenant en
charge 66 % et les ménages 29 % en
moyenne selon une étude sur le secteur
de la distribution des lunettes les
marges bénéficiaires des opticiens
s'leverrait à 233 %. en France le prix
de vente est 50 % plus élevé que dans
les autres pays européens cette
situation n'est pas normale en raison
d'une prise en charge insuffisante des
frais de optique et malgré le bénéfice
d'une mutuelle certains patients sont
dans l'impossibilité de s'équiper afin
de corriger leur handicap de plus ce
surcou n'est pas synonyme d'un service
de meilleure qualité comme le démontrent
les sondages effectués à la demande de
la Commission européenne en 2011 ainsi
les secteurs de l'optique du dentaire et
de l'autoprothèse sont peu remboursés et
les tarifs varient d'un territoire à un
autre il est donc indispensable de
réguler le système de santé dans ces
secteurs il apparaît légitime et au nom
de la solidarité que les mutuels
puissent proposer à leur adhérents de
diminuer le reste à charge nous devons
réguler ce secteur et éviter ainsi une
économie de la rente pour certains
professionnels qui ajustent leurs tarifs
sur le niveau de remboursement le texte
de loi que nous examinons aujourd'hui
permettra de faciliter l'accès à des
soins de qualité pour le plus grand
nombre en en effet son objectif est
double favoriser une régulation des
coûts de santé en vue de maîtriser le
reste à charge pour les ménages et le
montant des cotisations des
complémentaires santé évitant ainsi des
démutualisations améliorer la qualité de
l'offre à travers les engagements pris
par les professionnels de santé au sein
des réseaux ainsi constitués il s'agit
ici de combler un vide juridique
c'est-à-dire sécuriser juridiquement les
réseaux de soins qui existe depuis une
vingtaine d'années afin de rétablir une
véritable égalité entre les organismes
complémentaires en modifiant le code de
la mutualité ce texte permettra aux
mutuels de jouer pleinement leur rôle de
régulateur du secteur en leur donnant la
possibilité d'être des acteurs de la
négociation entre l'offre et la demande
de soins par ailleurs je rappelle que ce
texte répond à une demande exprimée par
plusieurs instances publiques la Cour
des comptes l'inspection générale des
finances l'Inspection générale des
affaires sociales l'Autorité de la
concurrence
elles sont toutes plaidé pour
l'ouverture de tous ces tous les
organismes complémentaires de la
possibilité de constituer des Réau de
soins de plus la légalisation de ces
réseaux de soins mis en place pour les
mutuels fait également partie des
engagements de la campagne de François
Hollande il est important pour le
président de la République de éblir
l'égalité entre les assurances et les
mutuelles afin de favoriser les
conditions de meilleur accès à tous à
des soins de qualité et au meilleur coût
on ne peut que s'en féliciter en effet
l'absence de régulation provoque des
distorsions de prix significatives entre
les mêmes prestations cette régulation
est nécessaire et urgente pour nos
concitoyens tout en précisant et
j'insiste sur ce point de la liberté de
choix choix du professionnel de santé
reste entière pour tout adhérent d'une
mutuelle quelle que soit la le
professionnel choisi au sein d'un réseau
ou non il conserve le remboursement de
sa mutuelle mais il pourra être mieux
remboursé s'il accepte de se rendre chez
un professionnel conventionné par sa
mutuelle tous les professionnels peuvent
entrer dans les réseaux de soins
contrairement aux idées reçues ils ne
sont pas réservés aux grandes enseignes
et ne défavorisent pas les petits
opticien indépendants à condition qu'il
remplissent des critères de prix et de
qualité le conventionnement assure en
retour aux professionnels de
santé plus de patients il est primordial
que tous les salariés puissent avoir une
mutuelle il était important que ce texte
soit présenté au plus vite au Parlement
car la loi sur la sécurisation de
l'emploi votée dernièrement prévoit
l'obligation pour les entreprises de
garantir une mutuelle à leurs salariés à
actuellement des négociations sont en
cours dans ce sens entre les différentes
branches professionnelles les
entreprises sont libres de retenir le ou
les organismes de leur choix ainsi avec
l'adoption de l'an on a on risque de
voir des entreprises se diriger vers des
organismes de prévoyance et vers ceux
dépendant du Code des assurances pour
que la mise en place de réseaux de soins
est déjà effective cette situation
serait en défveur des mutuels et
celles-ci s'en trouveraient fortement
amenuisé les mutuels ne doivent pas être
injustement écarté du dispositif le
texte qui nous est présenté aujourd'hui
est non seulement une nécessité mais
permettra d'améliorer le fonctionnement
des réseaux quel que soit leur statut
mutuel ou non je me réjouis de ce texte
car il va directement changer le
quotidien de nos concitoyens notamment
de ceux qui renoncent à se soigner parce
qu'ils n'ont pas assez d'argent il
s'agit de permettre la accès à tous de
tous à une santé de qualité il est donc
juste que le législateur permette de
régulation des prix pratiquer nous ne
devons pas tomber dans un débat qui
oppose la logique économique à une
logique de santé et d'accès aux soins il
y a eu déjà beaucoup trop de dérives et
il est notre responsabilité de poser des
règles et de principes je vous
remercie merci ma cher collègue la
discussion générale est close nous
passons à la discussion du texte de la
commission et nous en arrivons à
l'article prer avec une demande de prise
de parole sur article de Madame Laurence
Cohen pour le groupe crcle ch voilà mes
chers collègues l'article 1er de cette
proposition de loi constitue à lui seul
l'objet de cette PPL nous contraignant à
deux options qui ne sont pas des choix
véritablement soit l'adoption de cette
proposition de loi au motif que peu
importe les moyens à mettre en œuvre
tant que le reste à charge des patients
diminue soit se prononcer contre son
adoption et de fait continuer à accepter
les difficultés de nombre de nos
concitoyens à aller chez le chirurgien
dentiste à s'équiper de lunettes ou
d'audioprothèse l'examen de cette
proposition de loi couplée à
l'application de l'article 40 nous prive
d'un débat alternatif puisqu'il nous est
impossible d'amender afin de renforcer
la participation de notre système de
protection sociale dans les domaines
principalement visés par cette
proposition de loi à savoir le dentaire
l'optique ou l'audioprothèse où il faut
le dire les remboursements par la
sécurité social sont particulièrement
faibles je m'étonne d'ailleurs que
constatant toutes et tous cette carence
nous nous retrouvions aujourd'hui à
débattre d'une proposition de loi qui
désarme encore un peu plus l'état et la
protection sociale au bénéfice
d'opérateurs économiques privés pourtant
la rapporteur de l'Assemblée nationale
sur ce texte a été claire lorsqu'elle
affirmait je la cite cette situation qui
est de fait celle d'un système de santé
à plusieurs vitesses est responsable du
maintien voire du creusement des
inégalités dans l'accès aux soins et
génère des comportements de renoncement
à certains soins pour des raisons
financières hélas pour résoudre cette
inégalité sociale car c'est de cela dont
il s'agit on nous propose de combattre
la protection sociale obligatoire à deux
vitesses non pas en remédiant à cette
situation mais en proposant de
transposer cette situation à la
protection sociale complémentaire car
soyons clair nos concitoyenes et
concitoyens les plus modestes et vous
l'avez dit sont par exemple et ceux par
exemple qui sont assujettis à la CMU et
à la CMUC dont plus de 33 % ont déjà
renoncé aux soins pour des raisons
financières et qui sont de fait parmi
les plus nombreux à renoncer aux soins
ne seront pas demain mieux remboursés
qu'il ne l'était hier et ne
bénéficieront d'aucun accès facilité aux
soins les personnes âgées ou en
situation de handicap qui peine à se
déplacer et dont les frais de santé sont
parmi les plus importants s'ils ne
peuvent s'inscrire dans un réseau de de
soin en raison de leur manque de
mobilité seront discriminés par rapport
aux autres adhérents qui peuvent eux
sans difficulté se déplacer quant à
celles et ceux qui ne peuvent souscrire
une mutuelle faute de moyens suffisants
mais ne sont pas non plus bénéficiaires
pour autant de la CMU ils ne verront pas
après l'adoption de cette loi une
amélioration quelconque dans leur accès
aux soins et pour cause pour ces
derniers d'une manière générale pour
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens la seule
manière efficace de de réduire les
inégalités territoriales et social en
santé réside dans le renforcement de
notre système de protection sociale j'ai
bien compris en commission et
aujourd'hui encore que cet objectif
était partagé au-delà des rangs du
groupe CRC je m'en réjouis nous avons
les mêmes valeurs mais ça ne suffit pas
chers collègues où sont les actes
communs comment interpréter le fait que
comme sous le précédent quinquena les 30
milliards d'exonération de cotisation
sociale consenti aux employeurs perdure
comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le souligner
lors de mon intervention générale
l'Annie madame la ministre encore
appauvri la sécurité sociale de 2,5
milliards d'euros dans le but
précisément de renforcer le
développement des contrats
complémentaires comme s'il fallait pour
permettre le développement de tel
contrat affaiblir le seul régime
solidaire et universel qui existe la
sécurité sociale et aujourd'hui plutôt
que de renforcer cette sécurité sociale
plutôt que de rassurer nos concitoyens
sur sa place dans les années à venir
nous renforçons les complémentaires tout
cela nous inquiète pour l'avenir puisque
nous nignorons rien des tentations que
certains nourrissent de substituer
progressivement à la sécurité sociale
des mutuels et de transférer son
financement des richesses produites par
le travail sur la consommation soit par
une augmentation de la CSG soit par
celle de la TVA il suffit d'ailleurs de
lire avec attention le rapport de
l'Assemblée nationale pour s'apercevoir
que cette proposition de loi pourrait
n'être qu'une étape vous comprendrez mes
chers collègues que dès aujourd'hui nous
réaffirmions au groupe CRC que pour nous
seul l'élargissement du du périmètre et
du niveau de remboursement des soins par
la Sécurité Sociale est de nature à
réduire efficacement et solidairement le
reste à charge que supportent
actuellement nos concitoyens et il faut
effectivement avoir le courage de le
faire ensemble or malheureusement c'est
précisément l'inverse qui nous est
proposé au travers de cet
article merci je passe la parole à
Monsieur Philippe Bas pour le groupe EP
pour parole sur article
1er merci monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues je voterai cet article
premier mais je le ferai avec une
réserve je voterai cet article 1er parce
que j'estime que les dépenses de santé
qui ne sont que faiblement remboursées
par l'Assurance maladie doivent elles
aussi faire l'objet d'une régulation et
que cette régulation ne pourra pas être
le fait de l'assurance maladie elle-même
elle doit faire l'objet d'une régulation
pour trois raisons d'abord pour une
raison de maîtr prise du niveau de la
dépense deuxièmement pour une raison qui
tient à la qualité des soins sur
laquelle il faut être exigeant et ce
sera l'objet de ma réserve et pour une
troisième raison qui est liée aux deux
autres qui est celle tout simplement de
l'accès aux soins dans un domaine de la
santé plutôt dans des domaines de la
santé où cet accès au soins est plus
difficile que dans d'autres domaines
comp tenu du niveau de remboursement par
l'assurance maladie je crois que la
situation actuelle dans laquelle il y a
une distinction qui ne repose sur aucune
justification d'intérêt public entre les
institutions de prévoyance les sociétés
d'assurance d'une part et d'autre part
les mutuels ne doit pas perdurer après
l'arrêt de la Cour de cassation qui a
été justement rappelé tout à l'heure
notamment par notre collègue Alain
Milon j'estime donc donc que tous les
assureurs complémentaires doivent être
traités de la même façon et j'estime
qu'il faut encourager les mutuels qui
participe à une hauteur très importante
au remboursement des soins à adopté de
plus en plus un comportement de
régulateur et non pas de payeur aveugle
je crois toutefois et c'est la réserve
que je voulais formuler qu'il est
extrêmement important que les pouvoirs
publics ne se désintéressent pas du
contenu des conventions qui pourront
être conclues avec les audioprothésistes
avec les opticiens
ou avec les chirurgiens dentistes car le
véritable écueil de ces réseaux de soins
c'est naturellement la qualité des soins
si la pression se fait uniquement sur la
baisse des prix des tarifs et non pas
sur la hausse de la qualité alors nous y
aurons perdu du point de vue de la
qualité des soins et de l'accès au au
soins et par conséquent je soutiendrai
très fermement l'amendement qui a été
présenté tout à l'heure au nom du groupe
UMP ou qui qui le sera mais qui a été
présenté pendant la discussion générale
par Alain Milon et qui consiste à dire
que le contenu des conventions pour ces
réseaux doit être déterminé par un
décret en Conseil d'État et sous cette
sous cette réserve je soutiendrai dans
son principe la mise en place de ces
réseaux et donc je voterai cet article
premier
merci mon cher collègue nous passons à
la discussion des amendements mais ils
ne sont pas défendu donc les deux
amendements tombent et nous arrivons au
vote sur l'article 1er pas de demande
d'explication de vote monsieur Savari
vous avez la parole pour explication de
vote
oui moi monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre j'aiété très sensible aux
arguments de de de mon collègue et c'est
pour des raisons pratiquement identiques
au contraire je ne voterai pas euh
l'article
1er identique en ce sens
qu'effectivement il y a un alignement
moi ce qui me choque par contre c'est
que l'anement se fasse du secteur non
marchand sur le secteur marchand donc ça
c'est la porte ouverte à des arguments
qui ont été bien développés déjà par
Alain Milon et qui fait que demain nous
pouvons avoir des prestations à Bakou
qui seraient préjudicibl par rapport au
services rendu et puis je pense
également que ça rend d'avantage captif
à à la fois les patients mais également
les les les les prestataires euh moi je
rappellerai également au passage qu'on
voit bien que lorsque l'on crée une
brèche certains s'y engouffrent
rapidement je voudrais parler dans le
domaine des assistances à l'aide
auditive pour les
malentendants pas forcé pas forcément
euh euh ayant des conséquences
pathologiques mais au début des baisses
de l'quité auditive où on voit bien
qu'il y a des nouveau matériel tels que
les assistants Sonalto pour ne pas citer
de marqu mais citer un type de
prestation qui est en train de se mettre
sur pied avec un marché estimé à plus
d'un milliard d'euros il y a un article
très intéressant dans
Je un
journal bien bien connu et qui montre
bien les différences de prix puisque on
va derrière et ça peut être l'objet d'un
réseau favoriser ce type de matériel qui
n'a pas de vocation médicale mais plutôt
une une vocation médico-sociale pour un
coût de 300 € par rapport à une prothèse
auditive dont les coûts sont proches de
1500 à 1800 € mais qui par contre
traitent véritablement le
problème de diminution de l'audition et
puis rappelez qu'É ement il y a un coût
sociétal pour les mutuels qui est quand
même relativement importante puisque il
y a des aides pour acquérir les mutuels
qui vont être renforcé dans le cadre des
accords de l'an il y a également des
diminutions fiscales des diminution de
cotisation sociale pour un coût estimé
là aussi il y a une revue une presse qui
est abondante là-dessus pour un coût de
5,6 milliards d'euros qui va être
renforcé de milliards d'euros qui font
que effectivement il y a un coût plus
important pour l'état de prise en compte
des muels qui s'additionnent aux
prestations sociales c'est la raison
pour laquelle pour ma part je seraiis
contre cet article
premier merci la parole est à Monsieur
Husson
oui mes chers collègues pour vous
confirmer que je voterai cet article
1ier
je l'ai dit mais je veux le redire
d'abord par un souci d'équité entre les
acteurs exerçants dans le cadre de des
complément du secteur du remboursement
complémentaire au Régime Obligatoire je
veux également rappeler qu'au cours de
la Table Ronde l'ensemble des acteurs à
la fois ont exposé leurs considérant et
se sont retrouvés dans une unanimité
moins un acteur pour considérer que
c'est un bon dispositif je veux donc le
souligner à nouveau c'est une question
de justice et c'est une question de
justice et je fais à nouveau appel au
débat que nous avions eu lors de
l'accord national interprofessionnel
pour les acteurs de l'économie sociale
et solidaire puisque le code de la
mutualité enfin les mutuels font partie
de l'économie sociale et solidaire et je
trouve parfois un peu surprenant sur nos
bans quelle que soit la sensibilité
qu'on ne s'intéresse pas suffisamment
aux besoins et au mode de vie de nos
concitoyens et et d'une certaine manière
il recherche quoi il recherche des
garanties des services et puis des
niveaux d'écoute et de services
différenciés quels que soient les
acteurs et ben permettons à tous ces
acteurs du secteur de l'assurance alors
j'ai entendu tout à l'heure commercial
je pense que c'est c'est finalement
c'est un mot de trop puisque faire
commerce c'est pas une insulte c'est pas
une injure et le monde de la mutualité
les institutions de prévoillance et les
assurances ont chacune et chacun leur
place et au moins l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens en toute connaissance de
cause auront accès à des niveaux de
garantie et de services différenciés ils
pourront parfois avoir le choix encore
que dans un temps assez proche
c'est-à-dire lors de la
généralisation le le choix finalement
commencera à se
limiter merci mon cher collègue pas
d'autrees demande d'explication de vote
je vais mettre au voix l'article le
premier pardon je vous en prie madame
Alquier vous avez la parole
oui bien sûr
oui je suis donc saisi dans une demande
de scrutin public par le groupe
socialiste sur l'article 1er il va être
procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement le scrutin sera ouvert dans
quelques
instants
et tout
ouvert
plaî faut
voter
personne ne demande à voter le scrutin
et claud j'invite les secrétaires à
procéder au dépouillement de ce
scrutin
regarde
résultat du scrutin numéro 322 l'article
1er de la proposition de loi ça a été un
peu long parce qu'il y a eu un problème
de carton mais le résultat exact sera au
contendu intégral au Jio il y a beaucoup
d'écarts donc à une ou deux voix près il
en est ainsi c'est la transparence
nombre de votants
346 nombre de suffrages exprimés
317 pour l'adoption 177 contre 140 le
Sénat a adopté l'article 1er nous
passons à l'article 2
et je passe la parole à Madame
Jacqueline Alquier pour le groupe
socialiste pour prise de parole sur
article mettez votre micro aussi nous
semble être un bon
comprage de poser les bases des
modalités de fonctionnement des réseaux
de soins alors que ceuxci ne sont
encadrés par aucune disposition
législative ni réglementaire et je
voudrais remercier encore une fois le
rapporteur qui s'est attelé à ce travail
il est important de fixer un cadre c'est
pour nous essentiel c'est vital pour les
Réau de soins c'est respectueux de leur
fonctionnement cela ferme la porte à
toutes dérives il faut trouver le bon
dosage c'est la raison pour laquelle ce
texte est un bon compromis entre les
OCAM quel qu'ell soi et les
professionnels ou établissement de santé
un certain nombre de principes doivent
être respectés les conviventions doivent
l'imposer libre choix du professionnel
ou de l'établissement par le patient
critères objectifs transparents et non
discriminatoire pour l'adhésion du
professionnel pas de cause d'exclusivité
obligation pour les camp de fournir une
information auprès des assurés sur
l'existence d'un conventionnement ses
caractéristiques et son impact ce cadre
vous l'aurez compris est pour nous
incontournable il doit nous réunir sur
sur le même plan il doit réunir sur T
sur le même plan tous les organismes
complémentaires et viser essentiellement
des professions dont les remboursements
par l'assurance maladie sont minimes à
savoir les chirurgiens dentistes les
opticiens et les prothésistes les
médecins restant en dehors de ces
réseaux cet article pose le principe
également d'une attitude de vigilance
envers les opticiens les réseaux de
soins devront être ouverts à tous les
professionnels qui remplissent les
conditions fixées par les conventions
sauf pour l'optique ou la démographie
galopante de la profession impose de
limiter un certain nombre de
professionnels sur par zone géographique
ce sont également là des mesures de
protection pour cette profession qui
risque de se trouver dans de grandes
difficultés voilà toute les raisons qui
nous conduisent à vous redire monsieur
le rapporteur que nous apprécions la
méthode utiliser le cadre proposé cette
proposition de loi et son article
central représente pour les
parlementaires que nous sommes une
opportunité et une nécessité cet article
améliore le droit existant en fixant des
principes qui clarifient et si
nécessaire rassure quant au
fonctionnement de Cees réseaux n'en
faisons pas l'économie et ne perdons pas
de vue qu'au bout du système il y a des
patients et l'amélioration des soins de
nos concitoyens dont certains sont de
plus en plus
fragilisé merci ma chè collègue je passe
la parole à Monsieur Dominique vatrin
pour le groupe CRC pour la prise de
parole sur l'article 2
oui l'article 2 de cette proposition de
loi bien que modifié par le rapporteur
de la commission des affaires sociales
nous interroge dans la mesure où de
toute évidence le champ des réseaux de
soins des remboursements différenciers
qui vont s'y appliquer est bien plus
vaste que celui des trois domaines pris
à chaque fois en exemple que sont le
dentaire l'optique et
l'audioprothèse en effet si l'exposé des
motifs de la proposition de loi visait
explicitement les dentistes les
opticiens et les
audioprothésistes la rédaction actuelle
fait référence aux professionnels de
santé aux établissements et services de
santé au final pourrait donc être
concerné par cette proposition de loi
l'ensemble des professions réglementées
par le code de la santé publique ainsi
que les autres intervenants de la
production de services de santé soit de
multiples professions potentiel et les
propos de madame la ministre ne nous
rassurent pas sur ce point en tout cas
pour l'avenir je note d'ailleurs que
cette proposition de loi permettra
également aux organismes complémentaires
mutuels comme privée de conclure des
conventions des établissements de santé
sans que ces derniers ne se voient
imposer des règles de bon sens comme par
exemple le respect des tarifs opposables
al si l'on veut défendre les patients ne
faudrait-il pas commencer par là en
réalité sans l'avouer réellement cette
proposition de loi permet aux opérateurs
économiques qui viennent compléter pour
ne pas dire concurrencer la sécurité
sociale de constituer un système
parallèle de soins américaine
DHMO pour he's maintenance
organization pour mémoire ces systèmes
reposent sur des organisme privés qui
gère la protection sociale que les
grandes entreprises accordent à leurs
salariés ils agréent médecins et
hôpitaux et surveille les dépenses des
patients ainsi que les prescriptions des
praticiens or ce système entre en
concurrence frontale avec les fondements
et la visée même de notre système de
protection sociale obligatoire issu des
Lutes sociales et de la Libération il va
par contre dans le sens du projet de
directive élaboré par la commission
européenne qui demande de lever toutes
les barrières une activité commerciale
de santé exige le respect de l'égalité
de traitement entre tous les opérateurs
économiques de santé privée comme publ
ce que le groupe CRC continue à
combattre d'autre part il n'est pas
possible de passer sous silence le
mouvement de centrifugeuse qui écarte
les populations les plus fragiles
économiquement notamment RA on du coup
même des complémentaires ni les risques
possibles d'une restriction de l'offre
accessible dans les territoires ruraux
les réseaux ont en effet tendance à se
concentrer autour des centres urbains
voulons-nous un système qui repose non
plus sur
l'universalité garantie par la loi mais
sur une logique de conventionnement
c'est pourtant cette logique qui est
déjà mise en œuvre dans le régime
obligatoire de base et qui loin de faire
la preuve de son efficacité démandte
plutôt ses limites à titre d'exemple
le conventionnement qui permet aux
professionnels de santé de bénéficier
d'une prise en charge partielle de leur
cotisation sociale en contrepartie du
respect des tarifs opposables n'empêche
et ne limite en rien l'explosion des
dépassements d'onorair que nos
concitoyens perçoivent à raison comme
étant une discrimination tarifaire dans
l'accès aux soins qui plus est la
politique conventionnelle dans ce projet
de loi se réclame et avant tout destiné
à la médecine générale et libérale et
correspond mal à d'autres formes de
médecine comme celle pratiqué dans les
centres de santé ces derniers se sont
d'ailleurs vu appliquer une tacite
reconduction de la convention précédente
calqué pour l'essentiel sur ce qui est
prévu pour les médecins généralist ça ne
prend donc pas en compte la plus-value
qu'ils apporte dans la qualité et
l'accès aux soins de plus ce risque ce
texte plus exactement risque par
contrecoup d'impater le modèle
économique de ces centres de santé la
Fédération nationale des centres de
santé la Mutualité que nous avons reçu
dans le cadre de cette proposition de
loi regrette d'avoir été mise devant le
fait accompli aurait préféré qu'une
véritable négociation puisse s'ouvrir
avec les centres de santé pour toutes
ces raisons le groupe CRC ne soutiendra
pas cet
article merci mon cher collègue nous
passons à la discussion des amendements
et il y a neuf amendements faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune
l'amendement numéro 5 rectifié présenté
par Monsieur Milon oui oui monsieur le
Président merci euh nous proposons donc
dans cet article 2 de remplacer de
supprimer les les alinéa 4 à 8 et de les
remplacer par deux alinéas que vous
pouvez lire dans votre document euh le
ce présent amendement donc qui est
présenté par plusieurs de mes collègues
prévoit qu'un décret en Conseil d'État
en concertation avec les professionnels
concernés apporte des garanties
concrètes en fixant précisément les
règles de tout conventionnement par
l'ensemble des organismes
complémentaires nous considérons
nécessaire que les règles de
conventionnement appliqué par les
organismes complémentaires soitent en
plus harmonisé par ailleurs cet
amendement propose que les réseaux de
soins soient ouverts et ne permettent
donc pas de numérus closus afin de
préserver l'indépendance des
professionnels ces principes sont selon
nous de nature à rassurer tant les prof
professionnels concernés que les assurés
et permettrait de diminuer les restes à
charge sans enfermer les praticiens dans
des réseaux ni restreindre la liberté de
choix des patients je tiens à souligner
que cet amendement reprend d'ailleurs en
partie le texte du compromis qui avait
été trouvé en commission mixte paritaire
lors de la discussion de la loi Fourcade
nous n'avons pas repris
l'expérimentation pour 3 ans mais il
nous semble cependant indispensable
d'uniformiser les modes de
tion merci mon cher collègue amendement
13 rectifié présenté par Madame
procassia merci monsieur le Président
dans cet amendement nous voulons
affirmer que un la prestation médicale
ne peut-être un acte
commercial transférer à des sociétés
financières non soumise au code des
assurances au code de la mutualité ou de
la sécurité sociale une partie des
prérogatives de l'assurance maladie ne
nous paraît pas être en matière de
politique sanentaire une bonne gestion
et même être une dérive euh c'est
pourquoi nous proposons de supprimer la
notion de par l'intermédiaire d'un/ers
parce que un/ers commercial n'est ni une
mutuelle ni une société d'assurance ni
un organisme de prévoyance et surtout il
n'a pour seule vocation qu'une voocation
financière c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous reformulons ce paragraphe afin
qu'il respecte l'article L2 143 du code
de la sécurité sociale et donneent à
l'assurance complémentaire maladie le
même encadrement que l'assurance maladie
obligatoire en excluant l'introduction
d'intermédiaire dans le conventionnement
avec les professionnels de santé merci
chers collègues l'amendement numéro 10
rectifié tombe nous examinons ah
Monsieur requier je suis vraiment
désolé vous avez la parole mon cher
collèg président ministre mes chers
collègues l'alinéa 4 de l'article 2
prévoit que les organismes
complémentaires peuvent conclure des
conventions avec un professionnel un
établissement ou un service de santé il
s'agit par notre amendement de compléter
cet article et de prévoir qu'un décret
en concertation avec les professionnels
concernés puisse précisément fixer les
règles de tout conventionnement dans le
but de les
harmoniser merci amendement numéro 2
présenté par Monsieur valerenberg Merci
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues l'objet de cet
amendement c'est de garantir la
médicalité des conventions
complémentaires en précisant qu'elles
devront être conformes à un cahier des
charges établi par l'autorité
indépendante compétente à savoir la
Haute Autorité de Santé et nous avons
bien conscience que la désignation de la
h n'est en l'occurrence peut-être pas
des plus appropriés on nous l'a fait
observer en commission cela ne relève
pas de son rôle au motif qu'elle ne doit
intervenir qu'auprès des professions de
santé or certains des professionnels
concernés par le présent texte n'en sont
pas mais chacun l'aura compris il s'agit
donc d'un amendement d'appel parce qu'il
soulève un vrai problème
aujourd'hui rien ne garantit le contenu
strictement médical des conventions
conclues par les OCAM avec les
professionnel établissement et services
de santé ce qui est une lacune
extrêmement préoccupante du dispositif
mis en place par le présent texte en
effet la qualité médicale des soins est
intrinseement liée au contenu économique
des accords en question dit
autrement il ne faudrait pas que la
qualité des soins et matériels médicaux
soit sacrifié sur l'hôtel de
l'efficacité économique des 10 réseaux
or aujourd'hui les conventions sont
élaborées par les OCAM en concertation
certes avec les organes représentatifs
des professions concernées par exemple
la Confédération nationale des syndicats
dentaires pour le dentaire après quoi
elles sont soumises à l'avis de
l'Autorité de la concurrence donc les
conventions ne font l'objet d'aucun
contrôle médical
indépendant bien sûr la profession
s'autocontrôle et assure le respect de
sa bonne pratique lorsqu'elle dispose
d'un ordre mais ce n'est pas le cas de
toutes les professions concernées par la
proposition de loi de plus la profession
et par
partie au contrat quant à l'Autorité de
la concurrence va sans dire elle n'est
tout simplement pas une autorité
médicale donc par cet amendement nous
vous interrongeons madame la ministre
comment les pouvoirs publics vont-ils
contrôler la qualité médical des
conventions merci mon cher collègue nous
passons à l'amendement numéro 18 du
rapporteur merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
par cet amendement la Commission entend
inscrire dans cette loi le principe
d'égal accès aux soins nous souhaitons
éviter d'éventuelles dérives qui
pourraient aboutir à donner une priorité
à un patient non pas sur des critères
médicaux mais sur le fait qu'il
bénéficie de tel ou tel contrat
complément de complémentaire monsieur le
Président la Commission demande en
priorité avant l'amendement 5 le vote de
cet amendement ainsi que sur le
sous-amendement numéro 19
merci nous passons au sous-amendement
numéro 19 monsieur verenberg monsieur
roche sur cet amendement un com un
compromis a été trouvé en commission des
affaires sociales comme nous le
confirmera le rapporteur la commission
lui donne un avis favorable condition
que nous le reformulions nous en sommes
d'accord au départ il s'agissait de
permettre aux opticiens lunutier
installés dans des communes de moins de
5000 habitants c'est ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure dans le débat général de
pouvoir adhérer librement à toute
convention complémentaire c'est toute la
problématique du réseau ouvert ou réseau
fermé la première moture du texte ne
tranchait pas sur ce sujet clé il est
pourtant clair que ce sont les réseaux
ouverts qui garantissent la meilleure
accessibilité des soins à l'assurée en
particulier géographique mais remarquons
que même du point de vue du
professionnel le réseau fermé n'est pas
une très bonne solution dans la mesure
où il instaure un numérus closus
tournant tous les 3 ans l'appel d'offre
est relancé et de nouveaux prestataires
sont conventionnés remplacement des
précédents la clientèle se déplace donc
ce qui valorise d'autant l'activité
l'activité et place les prestataires à
la mercie des complémentaires c'est donc
tant dans l'intérêt de l'assuré que du
professionnel que le texte issu des
travaux de notre commission tranche
enfin en faveur des réseaux ouverts nous
pouvons que nous réjouir nous réjouir
qu'à l'initiative de notre rapporteur le
texte pose le problème la règle que par
principe les réseaux sont ouverts tout
professionnel peut adhérer à la
Convention cependant une exception est
maintenue pour les opticiens lunutier
nous comprenons bien sa justification
elle est liée à la très importante
démographie de cette profession nous
l'entendons ouvrir totalement les
réseaux dans ce domaine reviendrait à
l'évidé de leurs substances néanmoins il
ne faut pas pour autant en oublier
purement et simplement l'impératif
d'assurer un maillage et une densité
suffisante pour concrétiser
l'accessibilité géographique du service
à l'assurée pour irmédier nous
proposions que les opticiens ltiall dans
des communes de moins de 5000 habitants
pourés librement adhérés à la convention
mais nous avons entendu l'argument
pertinent qui nous a été opposé un tel
système générerait une rupture d'égalité
en particulier cela favoriserait en zone
urbaine les opticiens de banlieu au
détriment des opticiens d'agglomération
centrale nous retirons donc cet
amendement en lu substituant un
sous-amendement à la à l'amendement
numéro 18 qui a été présenté tout à
l'heure amendement de la commission des
affaires sociales en modifiant l'
l'alinéa 3 l'objet de ce sous-amendement
est de prendre en compte cont les zones
sous-médicalisées en particulier rural
et de montagne en précisant que les
conventions doivent respecter les
exigences de proximité dans l'accès aux
soins merci mon cher collègue madame la
ministre je suis saisi d'une demande de
priorité de la Commission sur
l'amendement numéro 18 et par conséquent
son le sous-amendement numéro 19 selon
l'article 44 alinéa 6 de notre règlement
la priorité de droit quand quand elle
est demandée par la Commission saisie au
fond sauf au du gouvernement je va vous
demander quel est l'avis du Gouvernement
cette demande de
priorité avis favorable est-ce que je la
priorité donc jeis répondre quand même
sur le fond du non d'abord la priorité
après il reste des amendements donc
merci pour votre réponse la priorité est
ordonnée nous passons maintenant à
l'examen numéro l'examen de l'amendement
numéro 4 présenté par Monsieur roche ou
monsieur
valerenberg
présenté par Monsieur
alors l'objet de cet amendement est de
garantir un remboursement minimal dans
le cadre du remboursement
différencié ce dernier en
effet doit conduire à bonifier le
remboursement au sein des réseaux je
crois que personne ne peut contester ce
fait mais certainement pas à
dérembourser les assurés qui ne pourrait
avoir recours à un professeur
à un établissement ou un service de
santé membre du réseau c'est le plus
grand risque auquel nous expose le
développement du remboursement
différencié parce que dans ces
conditions il aurait pour effet
d'accroître le reste à charge de
certains assurés et ce à à cotisation
égale ce qui est exactement l'effet
inverse à celui
escompté pour que le remboursement
différencié est un effet vertueux il
faut que trois conditions soient réunies
que le réseau produise un effet volume
et une certaine standardisation qui
permettent une baisse des coûts de
fourniture deuxièmement que la
convention au cam impose que cette
baisse des coûts de fourniture soit
répercuté dans les prix des
professionnels signataires et que la
convention en 3 impose à son tour à
l'OCAM de répercuter le gain lié à la
baisse des prix dans une majoration de
remboursement la deuxième étape en
particulier est un point clé parce que
si le remboursement différencié n'est
pas accompagné d' un corord tarifaire
les cam peuvent avoir la tentation de
financer la bonification de
remboursement des assurés consultant
dans le réseau en pénalisant les assurés
qui pourrai pas le faire c'est ce qu'il
faut surtout éviter pour ce faire notre
amendement propose donc de poser
explicitement le principe selon lequel
les conventions complémentaires ne
peuvent avoir pour effet de réduire le
niveau de prise en charge des actes et
prestation médicale en fonction du choix
de l'assurée de recourir ou non à un
professionnel établissement ou service
de santé et en conclu une convention
avec ces organismes on nous a fait
remarqué en commission que si la
problématique était réelle l'amendement
posait un problème technique et en effet
pour éviter une réduction de prise en
charge il faut une référence un standard
en quelque sorte et un ancrage dans le
temps alors pour éviter toute réduction
de prise en charge par rapport à à à la
prise en charge
antérieure nous pouvons effectivement
préciser l'amendement par un en le
sous-amendant en disant que ces
conventions que notre amendement ne peut
avoir effet de réduire ces conventions à
la date de leur signature le niveau de
prise en charge et cetera et cetera ce
qui est dans l'amendement donc on
précise à la date de leur signature tout
simplement merci amendement numéro 11
rectifié présenté par Monsieur
Jean-Claude
requier le Président Madame le Ministre
mes chers collègues la commission des
affaires sociales a souhaité interdir
les réseaux fermés sauf en optique selon
le rapporteur que je cite un réseau
fermé peut se justifier dans ce secteur
faute de régulation du nombre de
professionnels le nombre de
professionnels et de magasins
justifieraient d'utiliser cet outil de
régulation nous considérons au contraire
que tout professionnel de santé qui en
fait la demande doit pouvoir adhérer à
un réseau de soins dès lors qu' respecte
les termes du conventionnement il s'agit
de garantir à l'assurée le libre choix
de son praticien et d'éviter une
restriction de l'offre accessible aux
patients notamment dans les zones
rurales notre amendement vise donc à
interdire les réseaux fermés y compris
dans le secteur de
l'optique merci mon cher collègue nous
passons à l'examen de l'amendement
numéro 1 présenté par Monsieur
valerenberg il oui il a été il a été
défendu tout à l'heure
l'amendement numéro 14
rectifié 14 rectifié bis présenté pour
Madame
procacia merci monsieur le Président
l'engagement des organisations
professionnelles représentatives permet
d'assurer un véritable dialogue social
et un partenariat qui implique toute une
profession c'est la garantie de
l'adhésion massive des des
professionnels au conventionnement
lorsqu'il est le fruit d'une
concertation à titre d'exemple le
partenariat qui a été mis en œuvre
depuis 17 ans dans le cadre d'un
protocole MFP CNSD qui garantit au
patient l'indépendance du praticien et
lui assure qu'il recevra des soins
adaptés à son état de santé il organise
les rapports entre les mutuels de la
fonction publique et les chirurgiens
dentistes signataires et permet de
diminuer le reste à charge des patients
qui bénéficient d'une prestation
améliorée sur des honoraires plafonnés
un réel progrès en matière d'accès aux
soins puisque plus de 26000 chirurgiens
dentistes y ont adhéré sur 35000 le
conventionnement suivant un accord avec
les syndicats représentatifs a
d'ailleurs reçu la consécration avec la
signature par l'UNOCAM et les syndicats
représentatifs d'une charte de bonne
pratique c'est la raison pour laquelle
cet amendement propose que les
conventions soient conformes à à ces
modèles types nationaux déjà négociés
par les organisations professionnelles
représentatives merci ma chère collègue
je vais donc demander l'avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
général et pour la clarté du
compte-rendu nous commençons par l'
votre amendement et donc le
sous-amendement numéro
19 merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues donc je
donne bien sûr contraire serait
stupéfiant un avis favorable à
l'amendement que j'ai déposé au nom de
la commission et je donne également un
avis favorable au sous-amendement numéro
19 qui est en cohérence avec la position
que la Commission avait déjà exprimé
vis-à-vis de l'amendement donc numéro 1
mais cet avis favorable sur l'amendement
numéro 1 avait été émis sous réserve
d'une rectification de rédaction ce qui
est maintenant est entré dans les faits
donc avis favorable pour le
sous-amendement numéro
19 alors je reprends les autres
amendements euh monsieur le Président je
souhaiterit donner un avis sur le même
sur les trois amendements numéro 5
rectifiés présentés par Monsieur Milon
plusieurs sénateurs du groupe UMP et les
amendements numéro 10 rectifiés et 11
rectifiés présentés par Monsieur Barbier
plusieurs membres du groupe RSE RDSE
donc les amendements numéro 5 et 10
prévoi qu'un décret pris en concertation
avec les organisations représentatives
fixent les règles des conventions entre
les OCAM et les professionnels ils
reprennent l'idée qui avait finalement
prévalu après mout débat et sous un
autre gouvernement lors de l'examen de
la proposition de loi Fourcade je dois
vous dire que j'ai longtemps été séduit
par cette idée d'un encadrement national
qui fixerait les principes de
fonctionnement de réseau mais j'y ai
renoncé et ceci pour plusieurs raisons
tout d'abord au niveau juridique je ne
sais pas à quel point le Conseil
constitutionnel n'estimerait pas comme
pour l'an qu'il s'agit d'une atteinte
disproportionnée à la liberté
contractuelle tout dépendrait de
naturellement de ce qu'il y aurait
effectivement dans le décret justement
si nous voulons rester dans lespur du
conseil je ne vois pas ce qui pourrait
être écrit dans ces principes que la PPL
aujourd'hui en discussion ne fixe pas
déjà elle-même et je le rappelle
liberté de choix du du praticien
critères objectifs transparents non
discriminatoire pas d'exclusivité et
j'ai ajouté j'ai proposé d'y ajouter la
non discrimination pour les patients à
partir de ces éléments renvoyés à un
décret n'apporte pas véritablement de
plusvalue particulière je signale en
outre que ces amendements créés créerit
une insécurité juridique manifeste pour
tous les contrats qui seront nouvelé
entre la promulgation de la loi et celle
du décret ces conventions seront-elles
légales ce n'est guère certain et ce
serait très dommageable pour l'ensemble
des acteurs concernés par exemple les
conventions tiers payants qui existent
aujourd'hui avec les établissements de
santé seraiit fragilisé voire sans
fondement tant que le décret ne serait
pas paru ceux qui pénaliserait au final
les patients enfin l'amendement de
Monsieur Milon et celui numéro 11 de
Monsieur Barbier n'autorise que des
réseaux ouverts j'ai déjà expliqué
pourquoi j'aiestimé nécessaire de
permettre des réseaux fermés en optique
un plom 2000 diplômés sortent chaque
année des écoles leur nombre comme celui
des points de vente a explosé ces
dernières années cette situation est
totalement différente de celle des
autres professions de santé c'est
pourquoi un traitement particulier doit
être aménagé tous les rapports que j'ai
pu lire sur cette question explique que
les OCAM doivent être en mesure de fixer
un numérus closusus s'ils veulent
disposer d'un moyen de négociation sur
les prix or cette négociation sur les
prix elle est essentielle même si je
reprends tout ce qui a été dit tout à
l'heure sa notion de qualité c'est bien
cette négociation qui peut faire baisser
le reste à charge des patients en
conséquence de quoi la vie est
défavorable sur les amendements numéro 5
10 et
11 l'amendement numéro 13 a été présenté
défendu par Madame procassia il supprime
la possibilité pour les organismes
complémentairire de conclure des
conventions je cite par l'intermédiaire
d'un tiers là aussi il me semble que
nous porterions atteinte de manière
disproportionné à la liberté
contractuelle et à la liberté
d'entreprendre pour reprendre les termes
du Conseil constitutionnel donc la vie
donné est une demande de retrait et
éventuellement donc un avis défavorable
concernant l'amendement numéro 2 du
groupe UD udi cet amendement précise que
les convention entre un OCAM et un
professionnel établissement ou service
de santé sont établis en conformité avec
un cahier des charges adopté par la
Haute Autorité de santé alors j'ai déjà
indiqué pourquoi un cahier des charges
national me semblait inadapté à ce stade
de nos débats surtout un tel cahier des
charges ne serait pas de la compétence
de la Haute Autorité de santé qui est
chargé nous savons tous hein d'établir
des référentiels de pratique
professionnelles d'ailleurs lorsque
l'assurance maladie négocie elle-même
des conventions elle ne consulte pas la
Haute Autorité de santé nous avons eu un
large débat en commission et chacun je
pense a convenu que la Haute Autorité de
santé n'était pas compétente sur ce
sujet je voudrais rappeler aussi et et
souligner que les professionnels de
santé exercent déjà leur métier dans un
cadre largement réglement
notamment en terme de déontologie ou de
bonnes pratique les contrôles existent
déjà et le rapport prévu à l'article 3
permettra d'identifier d'éventuels
problèmes en conséquence donc de ces
éléments la position est une demande de
retrait ou alors ce sera un avis
défavorable concernant donc le je l'ai
vu l'amendement numéro 4 du groupe udi
c'est amendements concernent le niveau
de prise en charge par les OCAM
comprenons bien la démarche du groupe
udi aussi les conventions ne pourraient
pas avoir pour effet de je cite réduire
le niveau de la prise en charge des
actes et prestations médicaux en
fonction du choix de l'assurée de
recourir ou non à un professionnel si
l'esprit de cet amendement peut-être
bien compris et très largement partagé
il est difficile d'en mesurer et la pé
pratique car l'expression réduire la
prise en charge renvoie nécessairement à
une règle ou à une temporalité réduire
par rapport à quoi or dans ce texte nous
sommes dans le cadre des relations
contractuel entre un OCAM et son
adhérent ou un professionnel les
conditions de la prise en charge sont
fixées par le contrat qui devra prévoir
les conditions de remboursement en cas
de consultation d'un réseau ou non grâce
à l'alinéa sur l'information des
adhérents nous allons faire en sorte que
ceci soit pleinement informé des
conditions du fonctionnement de
l'éventuel réseau ce qui est un progrès
qui répond à mes yeux en partie à la
problématique de l'amendement donc
l'avis serait une demande de retrait ou
à défaut donc je regretterai de de voir
donner un avis
défavorable
concernant et c'est le dernier en
discussion là l'amendement numéro 14 de
Madame procassia en discussion pour
l'instantin cet amendement renvoie la
conformité des conventions avec les
professions médicales à un modèle type
négocié avec les organisation
professionnelle alors j'ai déjà aussi
évoqué cette question un modèle type me
semble aller clairement à l'encontre du
principe constitutionnel de liberté
contractuelle en matière de
complémentaire santé et je rappelle que
juridiquement nous ne sommes pas ici
dans le champ de la sécurité sociale en
outre l'amendement tel qu'il est
présenté sans aucune obligation de
résultat conduirait à une négociation
qui aurait une forte probabilité
d'échouer et ce qui condamnerait tous
les conventionnements existants dans les
professions concernées
à la lueur de ces éléments l'avis donné
à l'amendement est un avis défavor
merci monsieur le rapporteur général je
passe la parole à Madame la Ministre
pour l'avis du Gouvernement sur ses
amendements merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs je vais passer en en revue
l'ensemble des amendements qui viennent
d'être déposés tout d'abord puisque dans
l'ordre logique que nous avons adopté à
la suite de la demande de priorité pour
l'amendement numéro 18 de monsieur le
rapporteur
sous-amendé
par l'amendement
19 la chose suivante sur le principe
posé d'égal accès aux soins et rappelé
par le rapporteur dans son amendement 18
je veux dire comme je l'ai indiqué à la
tribune que je suis pleinement favorable
à ce principe à la réaffirmation de ce
principe même si j'ai eu l'occasion de
le dire la réaffirmation de ce
principe n'était pas juridique
strictement nécessaire dans la mesure où
ce le principe d'égal accès aux soins
est d'ors et déjà posé dans le code de
la santé publique je veux dire à
Monsieur roche parce que au fond je
comprends bien que l'enjeu en
réaffirmant l'égal accès aux soins il
s'agissait aussi de réaffirmer
l'ensemble des points qui sont liés ou
des dimensions de cet égal accès aux
soins égal accès aux soins pour des
raisons financières égal accès aux soins
géographiques également moi je veux dire
à Monsieur roche que que je et à
l'ensemble de son groupe monsieur
Valberg également que je partage cette
préoccupation de faire en sorte que la
constitution de réseau n'aboutisse pas
paradoxalement à ce que une partie de la
population pour des raisons
géographiques soit confronté à des
difficultés nouvelles pas nécessairement
accru mais nouvell parce que il y aurait
des conventionnements qui se feraient
plus facilement avec des professionnel
situés dans l'agglomération où les
professionnels sont en plus grand nombre
et se ferait moins facilement avec des
professionnels qui situés dans des
secteurs ruraux par exemple ou des
secteurs difficiles ayant un chiffre
d'affaires disons les choses clairement
moins important et pourrait présenter
moins d'attractivité pour les réseaux
donc je comprends et je partage cette
préoccupation je vous dis mon
interrogation sur la manière dont nous
passons de cette préoccupation partagée
à la réponse dans le sous-amendement qui
est le vôtre et c'est pourquoi je vous
dis je vais pas donner un avis
défavorable je donner un avis de sagesse
mais je suis je suis perplexe parce que
au
fond parler de proximité le le principe
de proximité est un principe qui n'est
pas défini juridiquement et donc le
risque auquel nous sommes
confrontés vous comme nous demain c'est
que la mise en œuvre de ce principe ou
l'évaluation de la mise en œuvre de ce
principe en tout cas par un juge le cas
échéant pose des difficultés la
proximité c'est quoi c'est quel
rayon en terme de kilomètres puisque
nous n'avons pas dans notre droit de
référence en revanche moi j'aurais
trouvé que euh la réaffirmation ou
l'affirmation de ce principe encore une
fois auquel nous sommes attachés comme
élément de l'égal accès aux soins
j'aurais souhaité moi j'aurais préféré
que ce principe soit posé dans l'article
3 à l'occasion du rapport parce que à ce
moment-là nous aurions pu dans le
rapport commencer à poser des références
des éléments qui nous permettent
d'apprécier concrètement ce que veut
dire cette proximité
et donc euh très sincèrement j'aurais
préféré que vous déplaciez votre
sous-amendement que vous le transformiez
en amendement dans l'article 3 et que
vous le retiriez dans le cadre de cet
article 2 si vous ne le souhaitez pas
euh je donnerai un avis de de sagesse
avec la en exprimant la perplexité qui
est la mienne face à la manière dont il
pourra se mettre en place euh
concrètement
pour où il pourra être apprécié
concrètement par un juge voilà pour ce
qui est des autres amendements il y a
les amendements 5 rectifiés 10 rectifiés
14 bis qui à des titres divers viennent
poser le principe que la loi ne soit pas
d'application directe en quelque sorte
et la nécessité d'un décret
d'application la loi la proposition de
loi telle qu'elle est posée telle
qu'elle est rédigée contrairement à ce
qui était le cas pour la proposition de
loi Fourcade et suffisamment précise
pour être d'application direct nous
n'avons donc pas besoin d'un cahier dé
charges queles que soient les modalités
de la discussion de ce cahier des
charges puisque dans les trois
amendements que j'ai indiqué la la mise
en place du cahier des charges ne se
fait pas exactement dans les mêmes
conditions je donne donc un avis
défavorable à ces trois amendements pour
ce qui est de l'amendement 13 rectifié
qui porte sur de Madame procacia sur le
fait de d'interdire à un intermédiaire
la possibilité de conclure ses réseaux
cela reviendrait
à refuser à plusieurs mutuels de
s'associer pour pouvoir avoir le même
réseau et discuter ensemble de la mise
en place d'un réseau et cela ne me
paraît pas aller dans le sens de la
proposition de loi pour cette raison je
donne un avis défavorable à votre am
madame les amendements 5 et 11 enfin
l'amendement 11 reprend une partie de
l'amendement numéro 5 pour ce qui est
des réseaux fermés je ne reviens pas sur
ce qu'a excellemment dit le rapporteur
pour refuser donner un VI dé favorable à
ces amendements je ne reviens pas sur ce
que j'ai moi-même dit à la tribune il me
semble qu'il y a là une question
juridique qui est posée et au-delà de la
question juridique une question au fond
d'appréci ition du mode de
fonctionnement de ces réseaux je ne
crois pas que la question soit de savoir
si un réseau est ouvert ou fermé mais
bien celle qu'a posé monsieur roche de
celle de savoir si l'égal accès aux
soins dans le cadre de ces réseaux est
bel et bien garanti pour ce qui est de
l'amendement numéro 2 je demanderaiis à
Monsieur van rberg de bien vouloir le
retirer s'il l'acceptait j'entends euh
son souhait qu'un que la qualité des
réseaux et la qualité des soins dans le
cadre des réseaux puisse faire l'objet
d'une évaluation moi je je je prends
l'engagement euh ici devant vous que
cette évaluation soit faite dans le
cadre du rapport qui sera réalisé comme
vous l'avez vous-même souligné monsieur
le sénateur la la Haute Autorité de
santé n'est pas l'institution adaptée
pour mettre en œuvre ce que vous avez
vous-même indiqué et vous l'avez
vous-même dit donc si vous acceptez de
retirer cet amendement ce serait
préférable sinon compte tenu de
l'inappropriation du rôle de la Haute
Autorité de Santé en la matière je
serais obligé malheureusement de donner
un avis défavorable pour ce qui est de
la de votre amendement numéro
4 je dois dire que je comprends la
préoccupation qui est la vôtre mais je
vous demande aussi de bien vouloir
retirer s amendement sinon je donneraiis
un avis défavorable donc l'amendement
monsieur vanenberg monsieur roche parce
que au fond rendre enfin
interdire le remboursement différencié
en disant au fond on accepte qu'on
améliore la situation et pas qu'on la
dégrade le sujet c'est par rapport à
quelle base de départ puisque il n'y a
pas contrairement à l'Assurance Maladie
une base de départ et que par définition
lorsque les les complémentaires les
mutuels vont conclure vont vont définir
des réseaux vont rentrer dans les
réseaux elles vont avoir la possibilité
de redéfinir leur contrat et s'il y a
dégradation de
certaines prestations à ce moment-là les
adhérents seront évidemment informé et
auront la possibilité de se retirer de
cette mutuelle dans des conditions
directes puisque il y a
modification du contrat donc la
dégradation d'une prestation s'apparente
à une modification du contrat permettant
à l'adhérant de sortir de se retirer de
cette mutuelle et sinon vous voyez bien
qu'on a un côté monter descendre on sait
pas très bien par rapport à quelle
référence on doit pouvoir apprécier la
situation donc si vous ne retiriez pas
cet amendement contenu de sa difficulté
d'application je donne un avis
défavorable merci madame la ministre
avant de mettre au voix ses amendements
il y a de nombreuses demandes
d'explication de vote je les ai toutes
noté monsieur Cardou vous avez la
parole monsieur le Président Madame le
Ministre donc j'ai écouté attentivement
tous les propos qui ont été tenus je
vais expliquer mon vote favorable bien
sûr sur l'amendement 5 rectifié présenté
par Alain Milon alors déjà je constate
que le Sénat a adopté l'article 1
l'article 1 qui se fondait sur le
principe et je pense que c'est un
principe qui a été détourné que les
mutuels doivent être alignés euh sur la
façon dont se comportaient les
assurances et les prévoyances or en
recherchant euh on voyait que c'était un
vide juridique c'est-à-dire que aucun
texte ne codifiait la création de réseau
ni par les assurances ni par les
prévoyances et donc on va uniformiser on
va calquer un mécanisme sur quelque
chose qui n'existait pas et qui a été
une construction sur le tas au fil du
temps avec certainement un certain
nombre d'anomalies ou euh d'Out trans
qu' aurait qu' aurait été logique de
pouvoir mieux observer donc je pense que
la proposition que le groupe fait UMP
fait à travers cet amendement et de
relancer une négociation avec tous les
partenaires professionnels pour revoir
comment l'ensemble des réseaux quel que
soient les intervenants puissent être
organisés et ensuite donner un cadre
réglementaire donc il faut repartir par
le départ et non pas se calquer sur
quelque chose qui existait sans
encadrement formel et forcément est au
cœur du problème cette qualité de réseau
moi ce qui m'inquiète dans ce que j'ai
entendu dans les différentes auditions
que nous avons eu et bien c'est que on
va évaluer on va vérifier on va et je
crains que se metre en route une machine
à broyer les professions de santé qui va
les encadrer et leur donner des
directives quant à leur comportement
professionnel or la qualité d'un réseau
ne peut peut se concevoir que sur des
éléments objectifs matériels
l'environnement la qualité du cabinet de
l'accueil du retour des actes de la
façon dont on s'y prend pour recevoir le
client et non pas sur la qualité de la
prestation médicale ce qui serait
interférer sur le libre exercice des
professions de santé donc voilà pourquoi
je suis inquiet et qu' me semblerait
nécessaire de remettre tout à plat pour
aboutir à quelque chose qui soit
acceptable et surtout qu'on se tourne
pas vers une 1è Haute Autorité des
réseaux pour pouvoir contrôler toutes
ces évaluations parce que je sens
poindre une telle solution dans les
interventions des uns et des autres et
enfin pourquoi je voterai cet amendement
concernant aussi l'ouverture des réseaux
parce que nous sommes dans une économie
de libre concurrence j'ai été surpris
monsieur le rapporteur d'entendre dans
votre propos tout à l'heure que la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel sur
l'an était inattendue alors là je pense
que si une décision n'était pas
inattendue c'était bien celle-là on s'en
doutait que le Conseil constitutionnel
prendrait cette position et là nous som
dans sommes dans le même cas de figure
donc je crois que la seule solution
c'est ouvrir un réseau et c'est la
qualité de la constitution de ce réseau
qui fera la différence et comme dans la
ni puisque la clause de désignation
était transformé en clause de
recommandation je ne pense pas que le
fait de recommander un organisme à des
organisations syndicales soit de nature
à diminuer la réduction de prix
qui que pourrait faire c'est cet
organisme d'assurance donc avoir des
Réau ouvert les constitués d'une manière
de qualité avec l'effet de groupe
mécaniquement nous arriverons à faire
baisser les prix et je crois que comme
dans tout ce que nous avons abordé ces
derniers temps la libre concurrence
est la seule garantie et de la qualité
et de la justesse des
prix merci mon cher collègue mais alors
je rappelle que nous ne sommes pas à
l'amendement numéro 5 hein nous sommes
au vote au sous-amendement numéro 19 je
passe la parole à Monsieur
valerenberg Merci monsieur le Président
Madame ministre monsieur le rapporteur
mes chers collègues vous avez madame la
ministre souhaité que nous reportions
nous renvoyions plutôt euh cet
amendement à l'article 3 c'est pas tout
à fait de même nature l'article 3 euh
c'est pour évaluer je conçois qu'il
serait nécessaire de préciser dans les
critères d'évaluation que la proximité
géographique doit en faire partie et là
donc je suis tout à fait d'accord si
tout à l'heure on peut sous-amender ou
amender plutôt l'article 3 ça serait
peut-être une bonne chose il y a déjà un
certain nombre de critères précisés on
peut en ajouter
par contre vous dites et vous avez
vous-même dit madame la ministre que le
principe d'égalité d'accès aux soins
c'est de facto
dans je dirais la loi je pense qu'il est
pas inutile de le rappeler ici comme l'a
fait et l'a proposé le rapporteur par
son amendement 18 et vous avez vous-même
souligné que ça visait plus exactement
souvent dans nos têtes l'accès tarifaire
mais pourquoi pas préciser et de
proximité géographique vous avez employé
le terme géographique de proximité
géographique je pense qu'à ce moment-là
on a une suffisante précision pour
pouvoir
permettre de d'agir si c'était
nécessaire dans certains cas
particuliers notamment dans les zones
rurales si elles étaient pas couvertes
voilà mon cher collègue alors est-ce que
cela veut dire que vous rectifiez votre
amendement en rajoutant
géographique
si Madame la Ministre maintenant on peut
laisser proximité parce que dans
l'esprit de beaucoup dans l'esprit de
tout le monde c'est géographique très
bien moi je veux bien rajouter
géographique si vous en êtes
d'accord monsieur le
rapporteur voilà monsieur le
rapporteur vous pouvez monsieur le
rapporteur bien sûr
oui j'essaie d'être cohérent et constant
dans mon positionnement donc j'avais
donné un avis favorable à la première
rédaction
bon il apparaît que celle-ci est en en
mesure de soulever beaucoup de
contentieux bon la nouvelle le nouveau
positionnement en fait de la même phrase
dans le texte comme principe général
peut madame la ministre l' indiqué
esttre éventuellement source de
consensieux mais moins que dans la
première rédaction donc moi je je suis
constant je pense qu'il faut se s'en
s'en maintenir à la rédaction telle
qu'elle a été proposée est tel que le
sous-amendement 19 a été déposé bien
merci écoutez je maintiens la rédaction
telle qu'elle avait été envisagée parce
que dans mon esprit il y avait pas de
doute euh la géographie c'est la
proximité euh bon et inversement bien
merci donc sur le sous-amendement numéro
19 il y a pas d'autres de si si sur sur
le sous-amendement alors euh c'était
là-dessus alors madame Debray vous avez
la
parole
merci monsieur le Président Madame le
ministre mes chers collègues ce
sous-amendement 19 hein
de me pose un problème effectivement
nous sommes contre le fait d'avoir un
seul réseau ouvert et je pose la
question madame le ministre sur le
problème de constitution fermé pardon au
réseau fermé je pose la question sur la
constitutionnalité est-il normal qu'il
n'y ait qu'un seul réseau fermé
c'est-à-dire celui des opticiens
pourquoi cibler C prof alors bien
évidemment vous allez me dire qu'il y a
beaucoup d'opticiens et que nous voulons
tous ici dans cet hémicycle légal accès
aux soins pour
tous pour autant je pense que si nous
adoptons l'amendement de Monsieur roche
je suis d'accord avec vous Madame le
Ministre je pense que nous allons
excusez-moi cette
expression fabriquer une usine à gaz ça
va être extrêmement compliqué c'est pour
ça que nous préférons que ces réseaux
comme l'a dit très justement notre
collègue tout à l'heure soit tous des
réseaux ouverts ça c'est la première
chose si vous commencez à dire zone
urbaine zone rurale plus ou moins de
5000 habitants ça va être extrêmement
compliqué à mettre en place c'est pour
ça que nous avions aussi en commission
et notre collègue de groupe communiste
l'avait soulevé aussi pourquoi si on
veut réguler effectivement cette
profession ne pas faire comme nous le
faisons pour les pharmaciens
c'est-à-dire en nombre d'habitants pour
l'installation d'un icien plutôt que de
les forcer à être en réseau fermé et
c'est pour ça que même si l'amendement
de notre collègue roche va un petit peu
dans notre sens c'estàd d'assouplir nous
ne le voterons pas parce qu'il ne va pas
suffisamment loin nous voulons nous ne
voulons pas de réseau fermés
exclusivement qui plusé pour les
opticiens merci alors explication de
vote sur le sous-amendement numéro 19
monsieur
Savari
absolument monsieurés madame le ministre
je je je suis un peu comme vous
particulièrement perplexe par rapport à
ces propositions parce que d'un côté on
nous dit qu'il faut véritablement
affirmer l'égalité de délivrance des
soins et par le biais du sous-amendement
on dit ah oui mais dans les zones on
fera des rurales on permettra peut-être
à des réseaux d'être ouverts alors que
dans toutes zones il resteront des
réseaux fermés c'est en tout cas ce qui
est proposé et donc il me semble qu'il y
a Rupt à travers sous un M de cette
égalité de délivrance des soins moi
j'attire l'attention de mes collègues
sur la difficulté des réseaux fermés ça
va véritablement tirer vers le bas un
certain nombre de prestations dans ce
domaine de l'optique vous savez il y a
eu des inondations au bangladesch au
bangladesch il fabrique des veres et des
verres d'excellente qualité hein qui
sont comparables à ceux que l'on peut
fabriquer par les grands groupes qu'on
connaît bien en France quand il y a eu
les inodations on s'est les groupes qui
proposaient déjà à travers ces réseaux
déjà existants à leurs patients des vers
provenant du bangladèch qui n'était pas
forcément bien sûr signifié sur la
prestation se sont retournés vers des
fabricants de verre qui ont été réalisé
en France qui montre bien que il y a
véritablement cette volonté à travers
ses réseaux de cette baisse des prix
d'aller vers des prestations lowcost et
on peut présenter que les réseaux fermés
vont faire en sorte que les ver loupes
seront pour ceux adhérant dans ces
réseau là alors que les vers médicalisés
seront pour d'autres donc véritablement
je pense que ce n'est pas une bonne
formule et que c'est à travers les
réseaux ouverts que l'on peut
effectivement peut-être avoir une
amélioration quant aux prestations
rendues et à leur
coût Merci la parole à Monsieur al Milon
pour explication de vote sur le
sous-amendement numéro 19 oui merci
monsieur le
président si je comprends bien on va
voter le 19 rectifié le 18 et une fois
que ces deux amendements sont le 19 et
le 18 sousamendé par le 19 une fois que
ces deux amendements seront votés les
autres tombent le 5 le 5 tombe si
l'amendement numéro 18 est voté du
rapporteuron donc j'ai j'ai en effet
quelque chose à dire à ce moment
bien je voudrais revenir sur
l'amendement de notre collègue roche
pour dire des choses qui m'ont choqué
dans les propos du rapporteur en
commission d'affaires sociales il a très
bien dit que il faisait de deux réseaux
ouverts pour les audioprothésistes parce
qu'ils étaient pas nombreux et pour les
prothésistes dentaires parce qu'ils
n'étaient pas nombreux non plus et que
par contre on formait beaucoup
d'opticiens en France et que en
conséquence il fallait faire des réseaux
fermés ce qui voulait dire que les
parlementaires le Parlement décid ici et
à l'Assemblée nationale de mettre des
opticiens formés par des écoles créé par
le ministère d'éducation nationale et
probablement par le ministère de la
Santé et de mettre hors réseau
c'est-à-dire de les condamner à mourir
est-ce que c'est notre rôle de condamner
comme ça des gens formés à mourir parce
que on les autorise pas à entrer dans
des réseaux c'est la première question
que je pose et à mon avis c'est pas
notre rôle de le faire on n pas le droit
de mettre des réseaux fermés dans dans
dans ces conditions la proposition de
roche c'est de dire les réseaux fermés
ça m'embête parce que j'ai des petits
villages dans mon département où il y a
pas d'opticien et les gens de mon
département n'ont pas de voiture pour
aller voir le peticien de la ville du
coin donc on va les ouvrir mais
uniquement pour certains types de
village mais uniquement dans certaines
conditions en fait donc on fait des
réseaux fermés ouverts un peu ou des
réseaux ouverts un peu fermés beaucoup
donc ça veut dire que c'est une usine à
gaz que nous ne pouvons pas nous ici au
niveau de l'UMP accepter ça me semble
être important un deuxième point je vais
essayer de pas être très long mais quand
on nous parle d'efficacité des réseaux G
entendu ce qu'a dit madame la ministre
sur le fait qu'il y avait un français
sur C qui renonce chaque année aux soins
dentaires et aux soins d'optique c'est
beaucoup c'est considérable ce ce que ce
qu'on oublie de dire c'est que ces
réseaux créés déjà depuis une dizaine
d'années structure déjà plus de la
moitié du domaine dentaire et du domaine
de l'optique et si donc un Français sur
5 renonce c'est bien parce que
l'efficacité de ces réseaux n'est pas
n'a pas été prouvée sinon il serait allé
dans ses réseaux et il se serait fait
soigner c'est le premier point une un
autre point une étude de Galileo
Consulting montre que les porteurs de
lunettes qui choisissent eux-mêmes leur
opticiens sont plus satisfaits de ses
conseils de la personnalisation de la
prestation et du service aprèsvente que
ceux qui suivent les recommendations de
le r assureur et dans le domaine
dentaire juste un petit mot comme ça
pour le
plaisir domaine dentaire qui est le
domaine de prédiction des réseaux fermés
la seule mesure sérieuse qui a été prise
dans la prévention dans dernières années
c'est-à-dire la prise en charge à 100 %
des bilans bucodentaires et des soins
consécutifs à 6 ans 9 ans 12 ans 15 ans
et 18 ans ces mesures de prévention ont
été prises pas par les réseaux mais par
la Sécurité
Sociale merci mon cher collègue je passe
la parole à Monsieur Husson pour
explication de vote sur l'amendement 19
oui mes chers collègues une une petite
réaction par rapport à ce que vient de
dire notre collègue alin Milon sur les
Français qui renoncent au soins 20 %
pour des soins ou prothèses optiquees ou
dentaire je veux quand même rappeler que
il existe des dispositifs notamment
d'aide à l'acquisition de la
complémentaire santé et j'ai en tête le
le chiffre je crois que en gros par
rapport au potentiel de Français qui
peut qui pourrai avoir accès il y a à
peu près un peu plus de je crois que
c'est autour de 30 à 35 % seulement des
bénéficiaires potentiels qui ont taxè
aujourd'hui ce qui veut dire qu'il y a
d'abord un problème d'information et que
si on s'occupait collégialement et
collectivement des 2/ers on répondrait
certainement à une des demandes qui est
de pouvoir améliorer l'accès aux soins
et pour cette question de l'égal accès
aux soins en tout point du territoire ce
que j'appelais tout à l'heure la
question de l'égalité entre les
territoires et d'accès aux soins et qui
rejoint
d'ailleurs la proposition de notre
collègue de notre du groupe centriste
moi je veux redire également que il vaut
mieux que vous explique à plusieurs
reprises aujourd'hui qu'il faut
peut-être éviter de
s'entêter une des solutions touche
puisque seul le seul réseau fermé qui
est proposé c'est les opticiens à
lunetier
alors la première réponse c'est si le
réseau est ouvert c'estàdire on va dire
de la libre concurrence pour certains ça
peut être un gros mot tout les problèmes
que l'on évoque
tombent voilà deuxième élément quand je
prends le rapport fournis par
l'Assemblée nationale où on a le
panorama des réseaux de de soins
constitués par les organismes
complémentaires on a six réseaux et
selon les réseaux avec des populations
couvertes qui varient de 1 à 3 le
rapport et bien chez certains on a des
opticiens 700 en réseau fermé et puis
d'autres 10000 opticiens réseau ouvert
dans un cas on a une population couverte
pour les
1700 opticiens de 6500000 personnes et
dans l'autre de 2005 et quand je regarde
les conséquences sur la baisse des
tarifs bien si vous voulez quand on
regarde pour ceux qui ont la moins
grande population 2 milliion et demi et
10000 opticiens lunetiers le reste à
charge pour les adhérents lorsque ils
sont en contrat individuel et de moins
de 50 € et d'un peu plus de 20 € en
contrat collectif ne nous trompons pas
d'enjeu soyez madame la ministre et
entendez la voix des d'une certaine
sagesse sénatoriale et je pense que si
vous acceptiez de laisser l'ensemble des
réseaux ouverts chacun y
gagnerait merci Madame deoche pour
explication de vote merci monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre rapidement
puisque mes collègues ont déjà tout dit
mais al la Milon a parfaitement décrit
ce que nous ressentons nous au niveau du
groupe UMP quant à la fermeture des
réseaux pour les opticiens comment
est-ce par le biais d'une fermeture des
réseaux pour les organismes
complémentaires que l'on va finalement
faire mourir des magasins d'optiqu parce
qu'il y a trop d'opticien en France je
trouve la démarche sur le plan
intellectuel tout à fait ahurissante ça
c'est le premier point deuxième point je
pense qu'on va arriver à un effet
pervers qui va être où les organismes
complémentaires vont continuer pour
certaines catégories de leurs assurés à
avoir des réseaux ouverts ou avoir du
moins des remboursements quel que soit
le pratique quel que soit le magasin
choisi ou quel que soit le le
professionnel de santé choisi on va
finalement avoir un réseau à deux
vitesses avec des mutuels pour les gens
qui onant les moyens et d'autres qui
seront contraint dans les d'aller dans
des réseaux fermés des réseaux où vous
l'avez dit vous-même monsieur le
rapporteur l'objectif c'est une
réduction des coûts et qui va juger la
qualité du rapport qualité-prix en quoi
en quoi on laisse les organismes de
mutuel juger de la la qualité des des
soins apportés même en matière d'optique
parce qu'on sait que l'optique c'est pas
simplement du confort c'est pas
simplement de l'esthétique il y a aussi
des tas de maladies optiques et
notamment je pense aux maladies la
réfraction chez l'enfant ou d'ailleurs
là mais c'est un autre débat madame la
ministre ce que rembourse la caisse
d'assurance maladie par rapport à à ces
maladies optiques de l'enfant est tout à
fait dérisoire et et mériterait d'être
totalement revu queles que soient les
difficultés financières de l'organisme
madame la sénatrice deux explications de
vote vous voulez prendre la parole
maintenant monsieur le rapporteur ou
après les deux oui d'accord je pense que
c'est mieux Monsieur laminii Vous AVEZ
LA
PAROLE merci monsieur le Président
Madame le Ministre chers collègues il y
a eu beaucoup d'explications sur ce
sous-amendement bon je partage la notion
de proximité de géographie de notre
collègue parce que bon c'est sûr que
l'argument concernant la géographie bon
je suis 100 fois d'accord étant
géographe donc je partage aussi la
notion de cette notion de proximité
après la notion de proximité il faut
aussi être prudent dans dans dans
l'interprétation alors à ce niveau-là
bon je partage sur un point mais de
l'autre côté bah les collègues qui se
sont exprimés je les rejoindrai parce
que d'un autre côté on a été quand même
beaucoup d'entre nous à être saisi par
par les opticiens je suis pas du tout un
spécialiste il y a des collègues qui
sont qui représentent les professions
médicales à paramédical qui sont
beaucoup plus compétents que moi et donc
qui peuvent beaucoup plus témoigner moi
je le diraiis aussi avec un un regard
tout à fait neutre et extérieur que dans
le fond après
euh bon beaucoup d'opticiens nous ont
interpellé bon après qui a tort qui a
raison ce n'est pas simple puis un texte
cet amendement qui a aussi le mérite
d'avoir été présenté par par nos
collègues notre position n'est n'est pas
simple de l'autre côté je crois qu'il
est aussi important de faire jouer la
concurrence alors donc je rejoindrai
aussi mes collègues pour en terme
d'ouverture si on peut dire merci mon
cher collègue monsieur roche pour
explication de vote sur votre amendement
oui c'était un peu pour expliquer notre
position surtout moi je crois qu'il faut
pas perdre l'essentiel du vote que l'on
fait aujourd'hui c'est qu'il y a le
secteur conventionnel où tous les
Français sont à égalité de chances
devant l'assurance maladie et puis pour
le reste à payer il y a les les mutuels
qui interviennent les complémentaires
qui interviennent et puis un secteur qui
est une jachè où la l'assurance maladie
n'intervient pas assez c'est tout ce qui
touche les déficit sensoriel c'est comme
ça et puis pour des raisons évidentes de
financement c'est très dur pour
l'Assurance Maladie d'aller sur ces
secteurs actuellement alors on se
trouvent actuellement dans des
situations où des gens de conditions
modestes n'ont pas accès à la à des
prothèses des qui pourrait améliorer
c'est leur déficit sensoriel et ça un
poids social extrêmement important pour
les personnes âgées qui rentre dans
l'indépendance par déficit sensoriel
bien avant le déficit cognitif donc
c'est et l'important aujourd'hui c'est
que la loi qu'on va faire ne va pas tout
améliorer mais ne va pas tout guérir
complètement mais améliorera ce déficit
qui existe dans notre société pour ces
soins des atteinte sensorielle alors moi
ce que je veux ici en tant que que
sénateur c'est je veux que ces gens qui
ne peuvent pas y accirir j'en parlais ce
matin en commission il y a quand même
des personnes âgées dans nos campagnes
et dans nos banlieux qui vont eu au
braderie ou au marché au puce pour
acheter des lunettes d'occasion parce
qu'il peuTent pas s'en payer d'autre il
faut bien qu'on fasse quelque chose pour
faire cesser ça c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui je dis c'est pas la
panassée qu'on fait mais il faut que
cette loi passe parce qu'elle améliorera
les choses alors cette loi ne peut
passer que s'il y a
il faut trouver des compromis entre nous
alors il y a le phénomène des opticiens
bien sûr il y a un problème pour les
opticiens et l'injustice que vous
dénoncez elle est réelle pourquoi les
opticiens et pas les autres mais aussi
il faut bien qu'on s'interroge on ne
trouve plus de kiné on trouve surtout
trouve plus de kiné pour aller à
domicile pour soigner un ébiplégique ou
quelqu'un qui a fait un AVC on ne trouve
plus d'infirmiers libéraux en campagne
mais aussi dans les banlieu et dans
cette centre Hurbain alors toutes les
semaines on va ouvrir un magasin
d'optique ça veut bien dire quand même
il faut bien s'interroger il y a bien
une raison à cela c'est pour ça qu'on
peut à mon avis trouver un compromis
c'est-à-dire que nos nos SS collègues
sénateurs de gauche et le gouvernement
tient à faire passer une loi qui va
beaucoup améliorer les choses il y a ce
compromis entre le milieu le le réseau
ouvert pour les opticiens ou non chîn à
fl fermé pour des raisons qui leur sont
propres et qu'ils ont à expliquer et
qu'on peut retenir nous on préférait
qu'il soit ouvert c'est ce que vous
dites aussi c'est mais dans la viille il
y a pas ce qui est blanc ce qui est noir
il y a ce qui est gris et ce que nous
proposons avec cet amendement c'est de
trouver un compromis qui permet de
préserver la présence des opticienes
dans des milieux en difficulté de grande
banlieu d'ailleurs ou à la campagne mais
c'est le compromis pour faire passer
cette loi qui à mon avis est une bonne
loi et que bien sûr nous
voterons merci mon cher collègue alors
après ces neuf explications de vote je
cède la parole au rapporteur
général merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers
collègues l'accusation portée sur la
portée de de mes propos par notre
collègue Milon est grave moi je ne
considère en aucune façon les opticiens
comme des adversaires ou comme des
ennemis et j'ai même un titre personnel
mais comme vous tous dans cette
profession beaucoup de proches amis et
je voudrais poser deux questions deux
questions en préalable la première
est-ce que ce n'est pas une profession
qui elle-même est en train de se mettre
en
danger par la multiplication des
surfaces de vente que l'on constate
partout dans la France et ça je je ne
suis en aucune façon responsable de
cette situation
donc peut-être est-il nécessaire à la
profession elle-même d'avoir cette
réflexion sans porter l'accusation
éventuellement de déboire demain sur un
rapporteur général des sénatrices des
sénateurs et un texte de loi la deuxième
question préalableil faut rappeler même
si c'est un peu désagréable mais il faut
le direon tous les constats aujourd'hui
mène à la con enfin mène au fait que les
prix sont plus élevés en France que dans
les autres pays comparables et les
constats mènent à l'idée que les marches
sont plus importante dans notre pays
voilà c'est il faut le dire il faut le
rappeler alors je reviens pas sur une
étude très documenté qui a été largement
médiatisé peut-être d'ailleurs les
chiffres qui figurent à l'intérieur ne
sont pas tous exacts mais d'autres
études viendront le moment venu
conforter cette idée que les prix sont
plus élevés en France bon alors quel est
l'objectif l'objectif c'est pas de
fermer demain des opticiens en aucune
façon
l'objectif c'est la maîtrise des
dépenses de santé et nous sommes tous
d'accord avec cet objectif l'objectif en
même temps c'est de maîtriser et de
réduire le reste à charge donc des
personnes qui ont besoin d'équipement
chez les opticiens alors comment obtenir
cette maîtrise des dépenses de santé
comment obtenir une réduction du reste à
charge un outil possible c'est celui qui
est en débat aujourd'hui ce sont les
réseaux de soins alors la question après
vient faut pourquoi faut-il que ces
réseaux soient fermés pour une raison
toute simple c'est que pour que le
réseau soit efficace il ne peut pas
comporter il ne peut pas comprendre un
nombre très élevé d'opticiens sinon il y
a plus de réseau sinon il y a plus de
réseau le réseau c'est une négociation
entre un
opérateur donc de organismes
complémentaires de santé Les Opticiens
dans lequel chacun doit être gagnant
gagnant et le réseau doit assurer un
minimum de clientèle supplémentaire à
ceux qui vont adhérer à ce réseau donc
dans une ville où il y a un très très
grand nombre d'opticiens et là je
réponds des questions qui m'ont été
posées en particulier par des collègues
dans une ville où il y a un très très
grand nombre d'opticiens si le réseau
est ouvert à tous ces opticiens et bien
tout se passe comme s'il n'y avait pas
de réseau et donc on perd l'efficacité
du réseau et donc on natteint pas
l'objectif qui a été indiqué avant c'est
la raison pour laquelle dans ce cas
particulier donc il est souhaité par le
rapport et par le texte que les réseaux
puissent être fermés je précise bien
d'ailleurs encore deux choses il y a pas
obligation qu'il le soit fermé c'est une
possibilité qui est ouverte par le texte
de loi et je précise encore qu'à ce
jour-là il existe en France de nombreux
réseaux avec des milliers d'opticiens
dont la très grande majorité sont des
réseaux fermés hein et ça existe déjà ça
existe déjà et depuis plusieurs années
simplement le texte que nous examinons
aujourd'hui va ouvrir cette possibilité
vous le savez donc pour les réseaux
concernant les
mutuels merci monsieur le rapporteur je
pense que le Sénat est éclairé madame la
ministre je vous en prie oui merci
monsieur le Président je crois comme
vous l'avez dit que le Sénat est éclairé
un mot pour appuyer les propos du
rapporteur l'objet jeu l'ambition de
cette proposition de loi c'est de
participer à garantir un meilleur accès
aux soins de l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens dans des secteurs dans
lesquels la barrière financière pour des
raisons diverses est souvent importante
c'est le cas en matière d'optique comme
dans d'autres secteurs mais c'est
notamment le cas en matière d'optique
vous êtes tous confrontés à des
concitoyens qui vous font part de leur
désarroi quant au prix de auquel ils
sont confrontés en matière d'optique
qu'en matière d'audioprothèse par
exemple et et d'autres domaines mais
notamment enfin on rencontre très
régulièrement des gens qui disent j'ai
des difficultés à pouvoir me payer une
paire de lunettes ou quelque chose qui
permet de de voir pour ne rien dire de
systèmes qui ne sont pas pris en charge
par la sécurité sociale comme les
lentilles par exemple donc nous sommes
là face à un enjeu absolument décisif et
je ne suis pas certaine que les
pratiques commerciales de certains qui
qui consiste à donner ou à vendre deux
paires de lunettes pour le prix d'une
aille dans le bon sens puisque elles
accréditent à l'évidence que les marges
existantes sont peut-être excessives par
rapport à la réalité des choses et je ne
peut qu'appuyer le rapporteur lorsqu'il
dit que les prix constatés en France
pour les lunettes par exemple sont plus
élevés que ce que l'on constate dans la
majorité des pays européens ou ou euh
proche de de de chez nous donc pour
l'ensemble de ces raisons je crois que
les dispositions qui sont prévues dans
cette proposition de loi vont dans un
sens favorable à l'accès aux soins de
nos concitoyens merci je vais mettre au
voix le sous-amendement numéro 19 j'ai
été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe udiuc sur le
sous-amendement je vous rappelle que
l'avis de la commission est favorable
que l'avis du Gouvernement est un avis
de sagesse il va être procédé au scrutin
public dans les conditions fixées par
l'article 56 du
règlement quelques
instants crutin est
ouvert
ion
personne ne demande à voter le SCR est
clos j'invite les secrétaires à procéder
au dépouillement de ce
scrutin
résultat du scrutin public numéro 323
sur le sous-amendement numéro 19 nombre
de votants
344 nombre de suffrages exprimés 322
pour l'adoption 186 contre 136 le Sénat
a adopté le sous-amendement numéro 19 et
nous en arrivons à l'amendement numéro
18 ainsi sous-amendé que je vais mettre
au voix je suis saisi d' une demande de
scrutin
public par le groupe socialiste
excusez-moi la vie de du Gouvernement
est favorable il va être procédé au
scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 du règlement et
le scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
personne ne demande à voter le scrutin
est clos j'invite les secrétaires à
procéder au
dépouillement du
scrutin
résultat du scrutin numéro 324 sur
l'amendement 18 nombre de votants 346
nombre de suffrages exprimés
326 pour l'adoption 189 contre 137 le
Sénat a adopté l'amendement numéro
18 donc comme nous l'avions évoqué tout
à l'heure l'amendement 5 rectifié
présenté par Monsieur Alain Milon tombe
et nous en arrivons à l'amendement 13
rectifié madame
procacia il est retiré merci nous
passons à l'amendement 10 rectifier
monsieur réquier est-ce que vous retirez
votre amendement suite à la demande du
de la ministre et du
rapporteur il est retiré monsieur
valerenberg l'amendement numéro 2 ou
monsieur roche deux demandes de retrait
de la Commission et de la ministre oui
monsieur le Président merci madame la
ministre mes chers collègues sur
l'amendement numéro 2 je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure dans l'explication évident qu'on
va le retirer puisque la hasas pas
compétente mais nous n'avons pas trouvé
de
réponse juste à une question qui me
paraît fondamentale c'està-dire du
contrôle médical de certaines
conventions quand il y a un ordre pas de
problème l'ordre est là pour
effectivement vérifier que les
conventions ne sortent pas des règles
déontologiques mais là où il y a pas
d'ordre les
audioprothésistes les
opticiens comment va-t-on faire
j'attends une réponse de madame la
ministre pour s'assurer
alors je sais bien c'est commercial
d'accord mais on est quand même
responsable nous en tant que législateur
de la qualité des soins qui vont être
prodigué ou au moins de la prestation
qui va être
prodiguée voilà pour ce qui concerne
l'amendement numéro 2 j'ai pour le 4
alors pour le 4 la question aussi est
posée du retrait alors je je je vois
bien la la
complexité aussi de cette
question ce que nous demandions ce qu'on
on avait essayé d'introduire à la
demande de du rapporteur c'était une une
clause qui permettait à la date de la
signature d'une convention
entre un
prestataire bien sûr d'assurer que
l'adhérent de la mutuelle ou de ne perde
aucun avantage déjà acquis par le
contrat qui court c'est-à-dire que il il
bénéficie s'il va dans un chez un
restataire agréé d'une
bonification et qu' ne puisse pas subir
justement une rectification de son
contrat et une perte de remboursement
alors j'avais introduit je je mesure
bien la difficulté he de rédiger quelque
chose qui sera de toute façon j'en suis
convaincu contourné par tous les
juristes dont pourront s'entourer les
mutuels les assureurs ou les
prestataires de tous ordres j'en suis
convaincu on c'est comment ça marche
dans le secteur des assurances je veux
pas critiquer mais ils ont cette qualité
de pouvoir par des petits éléments qu'on
n'a pas l'habitude d'ailleurs de lire ou
de comprendre d'introduire des clauses
qui finalement rendent inutile toute
intervention mais ce que nous essayons
en tant que législateur c'est de
protéger le sociétaire en ce qui
concerne les mutuels ou les adhérents
pour les autres sociétés d'assurance et
euh c'était le but de ce de cet
amendement numéro 4 j'aimerais aussi
entendre sur ce point madame la ministre
j'ai déjà entendu le rapporteur qui m'a
dit effectivement comprendre mais ne pas
pouvoir y répondre mais j'entends
j'entends bien avoir une réponse de
madame la ministre je crois que c'est un
point essentiel pour assurer puisque
c'est ça la volonté du législateur une
meilleure prise en charge des restes à
charge pour les adhérents des
complémentaires de santé merci chers
collègues madame la ministre vous avez
la parole pour répondre à Monsieur
monieur monsieur le sénateur je je crois
avoir eu l'occasion tout à l'heure de en
vous demandant de bien vouloir retirer
vos amendements de vous préciser la
position du gouvernement et de vous dire
pourquoi je tout en partageant les
objectifs qui sont les vôtres sur ces
deux amendements je crois que ce que
vous proposez ne permet pas d'y répondre
mais je reviens bien volontiers sur les
points que je vous ai évoqué tout à
l'heure sur la question de la qualité
c'est à l'évidence un sujet très
important cela dit et vous l'avez
vous-même reconnu la Haute Autorité de
santé n'est pas l'organisme qui
aujourd'hui a la compétence de pouvoir
vérifier ou édicter des règles de
qualité à destination de l'ensemble des
professionnels participants ou
susceptible de participer à un réseau il
appartient la la difficulté elle est
réelle elle vient de ce que les
professionnels concernés sont de nature
diverse et donc une partie de ces
professionnels seront contrôlés comme
ils le sont aujourd'hui par les ordres
auxquels ils se réfèrent d'autres
professionnels ne sont pas des
professionnels relevant d'ordre et l'on
pense notamment à tous ceux qui sont de
nature commerciale par exemple les
opticiens les
audioprothésistes ou d'autres dans cette
perspective là c'est une relation
commerciale qui existe il a appartiendra
au réseau c'est-à-dire à la mutuelle ou
à l'organisme complémentaire d'ailleurs
de façon plus générale de garantir des
règles le respect de règles de qualité
de la part des professionnels avec
lesquels il va ou elle va conclure un
accord on peut faire l'hypothèse qu'une
mutuelle qu'un assureur qui aurait des
retours négatifs de la part de certains
de ses adhérents concernant tel ou telle
profession n serait amené à rappeler à
l'ordre procéder à des vérifications
voire demander des modifications à ce
professionnel à défaut de quoi il le
radirait de des membres de son réseau
mais comme il faut aussi pouvoir aller
au-delà je crois que dans le rapport
gouvernemental qui va être discuté à
l'article 3 il appartiendra de voir
comment en relation avec l'UNOCAM
notamment nous pouvons avancer sur ce
chemin donc ce que je veux vous dire
Monsieur le sénateur c'est que c'est une
préoccupation du gouvernement et si j'ai
bien conscience que je ne peux pas
entièrement répondre aux attentes qui
sont les vôtres aujourd'hui je peux vous
assurer que c'est une préoccupation du
gouvernement je comprends que c'est une
préoccupation de ceux qui constittuent
des réseaux et il nous faut voir comment
nous pouvons aller de l'avant ensemble
avec des réponses apportter dans le
cadre du rapport qui doit vous être
remis sur la question la deuxième
question qui est une la question
euh oui sur la façon de sortir enfin
comment garantir à aux adhérents d'un
organisme complémentaire aujourd'hui
qu'ils ne vont pas voir à la suite de la
constitution éventuelle d'un réseau les
conditions de prise en charge auquel ils
ont droit dégradé je veux vous dire que
vous le savez c'est une des difficultés
d'ailleurs souvent les organismes
complémentaires sont renouvelés
automatiquement et donc lorsqu'un
organisme est amené à
modifier la nature de son contrat il
doit informer ses adhérents de ces
modifications et ce qui ouvre la
possibilité pour ces adhérents pendant
un temps donné de pouvoir
résilier sans conditions particulière le
contrat auquel il a souscrit et il va de
soit que si la constitution de réseau
aboutit à ce que certaines prestations
soi amélioré et d'autres dégradé il
appartiendra à chaque adhérent de
décider si les Nou nouvelles conditions
qui lui sont proposées lui conviennent à
défaut de quoi il résiliera son contrat
et ira adhérer à un autre organisme le
cas
échéant merci Monsieur valerenberg
avez-vous été convaincu par la
ministre presque disons NON je je vais
retirer ces amendements parce que je
vois bien la la complexité mais sachez
madame la ministre que sur l'amendement
2 le contrôle c'est pas de la PR
c'est du cahier des charges suivant que
vous le rédigez d'une telle telle façon
que vous proposer telle ou telle qualité
de produit vous pouvez avoir des
surprises les référencements sont
essentiels dans ce domaine et donc sil
pas contrôle du cahier des charges et
ben vous risquez d'avoir des surprises
et beaucoup de réclamations évidemment
parce que c'est une façon parfois
d'abaisser le prix que d'abaisser aussi
la qualité donc donc c'est ça que je je
dis vous seriez bien inspiré je crois
tant que ministre de d'avoir un œil
particulier avec les organismes qui
dépendent de vous pour que ces
conventions ne soient pas un
affaiblissement de la qualité de la
prestation et deuxièmement pour
l'amendement numéro 4 bon je comprends
bien je l'ai dit tout à l'heure la
difficulté et que c'est ça appartient à
chaque adhérent cor que hein quand vous
avez des complémentaires de santé qui
sont signés par des branches
professionnelles c'est ce qui va arriver
je crois que l'adhérant il va être
tributaire totalement de la branche dans
lequel il travaille donc on peut espérer
que les les les animateurs de cette
branche et puis les syndicalistes en
particulier s'assureront effectivement
qu'il n'y ait pas de baisse de
remboursement pour ceux qui n'iraiit pas
dans les réseaux constitués je crois que
mais c'était en fait l'objet un petit
peu de de cet amendement je vois bien et
je mesure la difficulté de le mettre en
œuvre mais je crois que c'est dans
l'évaluation qu' sera nécessaire de
mesurer les effets de
cette
préconisation merci donc les deux
amendements de Monsieur valurenberg sont
retirés monsieur requier vous faites le
pareil les retirer aussi le vôtre vous
le maintenez il est maintenu donc il y a
pas de demande explication de de vote je
vais mettre au voix l'amendement 11
rectifié qui a reçu deux avis
défavorables de la Commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour son adoption
qui est
contre abstention il n'est pas adopté
l'amendement numéro 1 est retiré
l'amendement numéro 14 rectifié bis qui
est présenté par Madame procaia qui est
maintenu bien sûr qui a reçu deux avis
défavorables qui est pour son
adoption qui est contre
abstention il n'est pas
adopté nous en arrivons à deux
amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune le 6 rectifié
monsieur Milon n'est pas
là Monsieur
Savari merci monsieur le Président
Madame le Ministre oui c'est une reprise
des align 9 et 10 en ce qui
concerne les professionnels de santé qui
ser du dispositif de conventionnement
avec parlant de rémunération comme le
sont les médecins à travers cet article
là mer mon cher
collègue amendement numéro 3 présenté
par Monsieur
valerenberg alors merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues cet
amendement vise à exclure toutes les
toute profession conventionnée par
l'assurance maladie du champ du
remboursement différencier et pas
seulement les médecins s'agit là à nos
yeux d'un amendement important et et qui
devrait parachever le bornage du texte
en effet la raison d'être de la présente
proposition de loi c'est de régir les
domaines d'assurance médicale
majoritairement déserté par l'assurance
maladie je ne reviens pas sur les
chiffres qui ont déjà été abondamment
cité et tout le reste ces domaines
d'ailleurs correspondent souvent à la
fourniture de matériel médicaux tout le
reste doit en être exclu c'est-à-dire
les domaines mixtes de fourniture de
servicees et de prestation médical
conventionné par l'assurance maladie et
ce à peine au risque de porter une
atteinte sérieuse et dangereuse au
conventionnement de base en commission
nous a été répondu que l'amendement
était sans objet parce que les
professions concernées ne pratiquent pas
ce jour de dépassement d'honoraire j'ai
bien entendu c'est ce que répondait
monsieur le rapporteur à cela nous
répondons deux choses d'une part à
l'avenir cela pourrait changer c'est le
cas aujourd'hui c'est ça n'a pas d'objet
sur sur le point des dépassements
d'honorair mais si on encadre
aujourd'hui ces réseaux c'est bien pour
prévenir aussi d'autre part et surtout
le problème n'est pas exclusivement lié
à la pratique du dépassement d'honoraire
se pose aussi dans le cadre du
remboursement de l'acte conventionné à
son prix de base prenons par exemple le
cas des masseurs qui
thérapeute aujourd'hui leur convention
avec l'Assurance Maladie prévoit que
l'acte est à 16 € et que le régime de
base doit rembourser 60 % de ce montant
charge complémentaire de rembourser les
40 ou un peu moins restants que se
passera-t-il si demain l'acte de
kinésithérapie est soumis au
remboursement mutuel différencié hors
réseau et en l'absence de
sanctuarisation des remboursements
actuels les 40 % du tarif conventionné à
la charge de la mutuelle risque de
fondre comme neige au soleil ce qui bien
sûr est extrêmement dangereux c'est tout
le conventionnement de l'assurance
maladie qui serait remis en cause et
donc le fondement même d'un système de
soins auquel je crois chacun et chacune
demeure très attaché dans cet hémicycle
le risque est particulièrement
inquiétant en période de carence de
l'ofre de soin il pourrait encore plus
un peu plus faire progresser la
désertification médicale et le
renoncement au soins donc pour l'éviter
il faut circonscrire précisément le
texte et donc exclure toutes les
professions conventionnées du
remboursement différencié c'est la
raison de cet amendement qui propose
d'élargir ce qui est prévu pour les
médecins aux professionnels de santé
n'appartenant pas à une des professions
donc mentionnées au 2e alignéa de ce ce
présent code voilà donc l'objet de cet
amendement merci mon cher collègue avis
de la commission sur ces deux
amendements vous avez la parole monsieur
rapporteur général merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues l'amendement numéro 6 présenté
par Monsieur
Milon par cet amendement les auteurs
interdisent aux organismes
complémentaires de conclure des
convention avec les chirurgiens
dentistes qui porteraient sur leur
tarifs alors ça me semble pour le moins
très préjudiciable pour les patients
d'abord on sait pertinemment que les
restes à charge sont comp élevé pour les
soins dentaires bien sûr cette situation
résulte de dizaines d'années de
désengagement progressifs de l'assurance
maladie mais le Haut Conseil pour
l'avenir de l'assurance maladie est
calculé qu'il faudrait aujourd'hui 3,4
milliards d'euros à l'Assurance Maladie
pour porter son niveau de prise en
charge en dentaire à 65 % qui peut dire
aujourd'hui que nous puissions disposer
des réserves permettant la mise en place
de tes dispositions il me semble
vraiment essentiel c'est tout le sens
des réseaux de soins sinon l'aprèsmidi
que nous avons passé perdrait sa
signification ça donc essentiel que les
OCAM puissent conventionner avec les
dentistes y compris sur leur tarif
l'avis donc de la Commission à
l'amendement numéro 6 et donc un avis
défavorable concernant l'amendement
numéro 3 du groupe
udi cet amendement prévoit que le niveau
de la prise en charge ne peut pas être
modulé et ce pour l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé n'appartenant
pas à l'une des trois professions donc
opticien chirurgien dentiste et
audioprothésiste contrairement au
médecins je l'ai souligné ce matin en
commission je veux le redire aussi les
autres professions dans la liste n'est
pas si longue que ça infirmière
sagefemme ma sœur
kinésithérapeute ne peuvent pas
pratiquer des dépassements d'honoraire
ce n'est pas autorisé par leur
convention c'est pourquoi il suffit pour
ces pour ces professions de préciser
comme je l'ai proposé que les
conventions ne contiennent pas de
stipulation tarifaire lié aux actes et
prestations de l'assurance maladie la
modulation ne peut en pratique avoir une
certaine portée que lorsque les tarifs
sont libres sinon l'OCAM complète la
prise en charge de la sécurité sociale
pour atteindre ou se rapprocher du tarif
assurance maladie donc il me paraît
vraiment
que la proposition de légiférer là est
n'a pas d'objet n'a pas d'objet parce
qu'elle ne porte pas sur des faits qui
sont une réalité aujourd'hui alors si
dans quelques années la situation devait
évoluer comme cela a été indiqué bah
nous sommes capables de siéger à 25 je
sais pas juillet après-midi sur ce texte
nous reviendrons un autre 25 juillet
pour modifier le texte d'aujourd'hui
toute loi peut à un moment donné
connaître une évolution mais autant j'ai
souhaité ENF je je le redis avec un peu
de solenité j'ai souhaité que ce texte
ne puisse en aucune façon être présenté
comme un texte d'opportunité comme un
texte de réaction à tel ou tel mouvement
mais qu'il présente un ensemble cohérent
par rapport à l'ensemble des professions
de santé et donc ceci concerne les
conventions passées entre les organismes
complément
et les professions médicales autant il
me semble pas aujourd'hui nécessaire je
dis sans objet de légiférer sur les
remboursements différentiels pour des
professions que cela ne peut pas
concerner donc moi je souhaite vraiment
pour la clarté du texte qui sortira de
nos débats aujourd'hui aujourd'hui que
cet amendement soit retiré merci Madame
la Ministre donnez-nous l'avis du
Gouvernement sur ces de amendements
oui monsieur le Président même avis pour
la ce qui est de l'amendement numéro 6
je ne reviens pas sur ce qui a pu être
dit ça fait l'objet au fond essentiel du
débat qui nous occupe cet après-midi je
crois que l'amendement qui est présenté
va dans le sens opposé à ce qui est
recherché par la proposition de loi pour
ce qui est de l'amendement numéro 3 moi
je proposerais volontiers qu'il soit
retiré je dois dire que par ailleurs
enfin d'une part l'amendement qui vise à
interdire les remboursements
différenciés euh pour l'ensemble des
professions ne tient pas compte donc de
la diversité des situations telle que
nous avons pu le dire par ailleurs il
est rédigé en des termes tels qu'en
réalité il ne n'atteint pas l'objectif
qui est celui qu'il s'est fixé lui-même
puisque concrètement d'une part il vise
les professions les actes médicaux
les actes médicaux ne peuvent par
définition pas être réalisés par des
professions paramédicales les
professions paramédicales par ailleurs
comme cela a été dit ne peuvent pas
procéder à des dépassements d'honorair
alors si tel devait devenir le cas nous
reverrions la loi mais je tiens à vous
dire Monsieur le Sénateur que l'objectif
enfin ou la volonté de ce gouvernement
en tout cas n'est pas de permettre
l'inflation des dépassements d'honorair
et n'est pas au moment où le
gouvernement est engagé dans la lutte
contre les dépassements d'honoraires
excessifs de la part des médecins n'est
pas de permettre que des professionnels
qui aujourd'hui ne peuvent pas pratiquer
dépassement d'honoraire y est accès il y
a une question de cohérence et de
logique mais par ailleurs pour ce qui
est de la rédaction même de votre
amendement nous nous
retrouverions dans une situation qui
aboutirait en réalité à ce que
l'interdiction des remboursements
différenciés euh ne concerne que les
sages-femmes ce serait la seule
profession qui serait concernée par par
euh les les professions paramédicales ne
peuvent pas le faire donc elles ne sont
pas concernées et les professions
médicales euh les pour ce qui est des
médecins la proposition loi empêche
d'ors et déjà que la modulation puisse
intervenir et donc les seules
professions qui seraient concernés
serait les sages-femmes alors même que
vous dites que l'enjeu concerne un emble
de professionnels on voit donc pas bien
quelle serait la cohérence de cet
amendement moi je vous propose monsieur
le sénateur de le retirer à défaut de
quoi je donnerai un avis défavorable
merci madame la ministre je vais mettre
au voi l'amendement numéro 6 rectifié
présenté par Monsieur Savari qui a reçu
de Oui Oui ououi deux avis défavorables
monsieur Cardou a demandé la parole pour
explication de vote je lui passe
oui merci monsieurésid Président Madame
le Ministre j'avou être surpris de de
cette position qui ne limite l'exclusion
des remboursements différenciés qu'au
seul médecin j'avais posé la la question
en débat lorsque nous avonsç les
représentants des mutuels en soulignant
quand même même si les médecins sont
exclus que d'autres professions de santé
on peut évoquer des infirmiers qui
suivent des malades de longue durée on
peut évoquer des kinésithérapeutes ou
d'autres que bien souvent un lien
affectif serée entre un professionnel de
santé et un malade et que on sait très
bien que dans le cas d'une thérapie le
lien affectif est souvent un élément
déterminant pour la guérison donc en
imposant des remboursements différenciés
on lit on risque d'éloigner ces patients
de leur professionnels de santé auquel
ils sont habitués deuxième élément on
m'avait répondu à l'époque que de toute
façon les seules professions concernés
étai les opticiens les audioprothésistes
et les prothésistes dentaires c'est la
réponse qu'on m'avait donné à l'époque
force de constater que c'est pas tout à
fait ça autre élément qui me trouble
c'est que dans les écho daté du 24
juillenne notre rapporteur a fait une
déclaration comme quoi il proposerait
des amendements excluant toutes les
professions de santé des roursements
différenciés manifestement entre le 24
juillet et aujourd'hui il y a eu une
modification dans son jugement mais
j'avoue que je le déplore j'ajoute
j'ajoute que dès le
début nous faisons je pense une erreur
de jugement dans ce dossier on comprend
bien que l'objectif et de permettre de
meilleurs remboursements dans les trois
secteurs que j'ai cité tout à l'heure et
pour lesquels la sécurité sociale donne
offre des remboursements insuffisants
tout le monde a bien compris or si on
analyse quelle est la nature de ces
trois
secteurs opticien audioprothésiste et
prothésiste dentaire et je dis bien
prothésiste dentaire et non pas
chirurgiens dentiste parce que les
stomatologues sont des médecins et les
chirurgiens dentistes sont des
professions de santé donc le problème ce
sont les protésistes dentaire et bien
ces trois professions ne sont pas des
professions de santé et la meilleure
preuve est qu'elles sont traitées
fiscalement différemment une profession
de santé est une profession libérale
assujettie fiscalement au bénéfices non
commerciaux ces trois natures de
professions qui sont ou des artisans ou
des commerçants sont assujeettis comme
des commerçants obéiss et autre argument
que je peux donner c'est que pour avoir
accès à ces trois intervenants et bien
il faut une prescription médicale donc
il y a une différence fondamentale entre
ces trois secteurs qui posent problème
quant au volume de le remboursement et
les autres professions de santé donc il
me semble et c'est voilà pourquoi je
suis favorable à ces amendements qu'
aurait suffit de flécher dans les
remboursement différenciés les trois
secteurs qui POS problème et de laisser
aux autres professions de santé qui sont
des professions libérales leur liberté
d'exercice et surtout leur liberté de
contact avec leur patients qui je le
répète bien souvent avec le lien
affectif qu' peuvent développer sont des
éléments importants des traitements
merci mon cher
collègue sur l'amendement numéro 6
rectifié monsieur non monsieur
Roch vous avez la parole pour
explication de vote sur le 6 rectifié
oui si on touche un peu les deux alors
je
vais il y a il y a il y a des choses que
je comprends pas tout à fait parce que
euh Yv d'din a essayé de me convaincre
et puis il a passé des heures et des
heures mais dans son raisonnement je
n'ai pas bien compris euh si on ne
laisse si onclut pas toutes les
professions
conventionnées du système
euh l'argument est qui est tenu dit
c'est pas la peine il n'y a pas matière
à le faire puisque on a comme l'argument
de mon collègue d'udini c'est de dire
c'est pas la peine d'interdire des
camions au camion de rouler à plus de
100 à l'URE puis de toute façon les
moteurs sont faits pour pas qu'il ne
roule à plus mais il y a quand même une
dérive qui est poss possible vous prenez
le kiné l'exemple qu' a pris tout à
l'heure Jean-Marie mettons 16 € la
sécurité sociale va va rembourser 10 €
et la la complémentaire en général 40 %
des des 6 € qui restent impeccable s'il
rentre dans un réseau comme ils sont
conventionnés il aura toujours les 10 €
de la sécurité sociale mais qu'est-ce
qui empêche les complémentaires de
remplacer de rembourser à 60 % le le
reste à charge euh dans le pour les pour
les quiinet qui seront conventionnés et
de rester à 30 ou 40 % pour ceux qui ne
sont pas qui ne sont pas dans un réseau
ça va il y a un risque de dérive qui
peut faire un peu je m'excuse du terme
et un peu magouille qui peut s'installer
et il y a un très grand danger de voir
ceci se développer par des des
connivances et les autres alors que si
on les exclut et ben ça sera euh euh ça
ce sera exclu par contre par contre s'il
avait fallu faire une exclusion de pour
les conventionnés c'était pour les les
les chirurgiens dentistes parce dans
chez les chirurgiens dentistes l'acte
qui est conventionné c'est l'acte
médical il y a pas de problème il est
conventionné payé par la sécu et et le
et le la complémentaire intervient mais
lorsqu'il y a lorsqu'il y a une prothèse
la prothèse c'est pas la source qu'il
faut réguler le prix c'est le le fait
le le coût que le chirurgien dentiste va
le facturer et je peux vous dire que les
coefficients de multiplication sont pas
parfois arri à deux chiffres et ça on
rég on ne le régulera pas et à mon avis
s'il y avait une exception à faire
c'était pour les chirgiens dentistes et
pas pour les autres profession en tout
cas j'ai pas bien j'ai pas bien compris
l'argumentation donc bien sûr je voterai
l'amendement du
groupe mon cher collègue monsieur
valerenberg pour explication de vote sur
le 6 rectifié sur le sur le 6 et sur le
3 alors si vous voulez
oui je je complète ce que vient de dire
euh mon collègue roche je crois qu'il
faut euh bien s'entendre s'agit pas de
dépassement d'honorair il s'agit des
compléments du ticket modérateur en
quelque sorte que les mutuels en général
remboursent et euh rien
n'empêche à l'avenir si ça se fait pas
aujourd'hui euh d'envie de de vooir
desquinés on prenait cet exemple pouvoir
bénéficier suivant qu'ils adhèrent à un
réseau ou pas
en de pouvoir faire bénéficier bien sûr
les mutualistes les sociétaires d'un
remboursement différencié qui soit
beaucoup plus intéressant alors que tout
le monde est d'accord pour dire il faut
les sortir toutes les professions
conventionnées médicales faut les sortir
du champ euh de ces remboursements
différenciés et là finalement je crois
que on on on est on légifère pas parce
que pour le moment ça n'est pas pratiqué
j'ai dit le législateur il n'est pas là
uniquement pour corriger et
être simplement corriger les faits mais
aussi pour les
prévenir collègue je mets au voix
l'amendement 6 rectifié qui a reçu deux
avis défavorables qui est pour son
adoption qui est
contre il n'est pas adopté et
l'amendement numéro
3 même vote même vote amendement numéro
12 rectifié présenté par Monsieur
Jean-Claude requier merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues la proposition de Loire vise à
réduire les inégalité d'accès aux soins
en précisant le r des organismes
complémentaires dans les secteurs peu
régulés où les tarifs son libre et le
reste à charge important pour les
patients bien que la Commission des
affffaires sociales a interdit la
modulation des prestations du fait d'une
convention entre un médecin et un
organisme complémentaire le texte
n'interdit pas aux organismes
complémentaires de pratiquer des
remboursements différenciés pour les
actes de médecine il généralise en ce
sens un système de prise en charge à de
vitesses pour l'ensemble des soins de
des soins de santé courant aussi il vous
a proposé d'exclure la pratique des
remboursements différenciés pour les
actes de médecine et ceux qui s'agissent
des mutuels des sociétés d'assurance ou
des instituts de
prévoyance collègue avis de la
commission sur l'amendement 12
rectifieré merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
cet amendement vise à n'autoriser les
modalisations de remboursement qu'en
fonction des cotisations payées ou de la
situation de famille lorsqu'il s'agit
d'acte de médecine l'exposé des motifs
parle de l'ensemble des soins cour
courant mais je note que cet amendement
ne concerne que les actes de médecine or
cette notion donc d'acte de médecine est
flou et je veux rappeler que les
chirurgiens dentistes et les sagesfemmes
font partie des professions médicales
selon le Code de la santé publique en
outre la rédaction d'amendement en
renvoyant à des actes et non à des
professionnels poserait certainement des
difficulté au regard de la convention
médicale de l'assurance maladie mais
surtout en tout état de cause son objet
me semble assez largement satisfait par
le texte de la commission qui ne permet
pas aux convention entre un okam et un
médecin d'entraîner une modulation de
remboursement donc je souhaiterais que
pour la clarté de nos débats cet
amendement soit retiré mais s n'était
pas retiré l'avis ne pourrait être que
défavorable madame la ministre même avis
même avis je précise que la la
l'amendement de monsieur le sénateur est
totalement satisfait par l'alinéa 10 de
cette proposition de loi de cet article
le sénateur étant satisfait il retire
son amendement merci Monsieur rquier
Madame procass amendement 15
rectifié merci monsieur le Président
euh nous avons dénoncé la logique
souvent purement financière des réseaux
actuel qui n'ont pas de base législative
ni réglementaire et nous souhaiterions
par cet amendement euh préciser que les
informations ne peuventevenir au
principe déontologiques fondamentaux qui
organisent les relations entre le
professionnel de santé et avec le
patient nous voulons absolument par cet
amendement éviter les dérives qui
transformment la prestation médicale en
marchandise et donc le patient en qui
fait l'objet d'un marchandage c'est la
raison de cet amendement merci madame la
sénatrice monsieur le rapporteur général
avis de la commission merci monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre chers
collègues cet amendement prévoit que
l'information des OCAM envers leurs
assurés ne peut contrevenir je cite aux
principes déontologiques fondamentaux
qui organiseent les relations entre le
professionnel et le patient si je
comprends bien je l'ai dit d'ailleurs en
commission l'objectif de l'amendement je
suis dubitatif quant à la portée exacte
de l'expression principes déontologiques
fondamentaux et par exemple pour
illustrer donc ce fait je ne souhaite
pas que cette référence puisse empêcher
les ocames d'orienter leurs adhérents
vers les professionnels du réseau or
l'interdiction de la publicité fait
partie de la déontologie des chirurgiens
dentistes et il ne faudrait pas que
l'information du patient soit assimilée
à la publicité il y a ce risque donc je
propose à ce stade de demander l'avis du
Gouvernement madame la ministre et de
suivre votre avis merci madame la
ministre vous avez la parole
oui je je dois dire je donne un avis
défavorable à votre amendement madame
parce que je ne suis madame la sénatrice
parce que je ne suis pas d'ailleurs
certaine de comprendre bien
quel est sa visée dans la mesure où les
règles déontologique elle régissent les
relations entre le professionnel et le
patient ces règles elles ne pe peent pas
être
transposé à la relation entre un
assureur ou un organisme complémentaire
et son adhérent c'est-à-dire que on ne
voit pas comment sauf à ce que dans
chaque contrat il soit écrit les règles
diontologiques des professionnels de
santé vous sont garanties et elles sont
vérifiées par les ordres ou par les les
autorités compétentes mais les règles
déontologiques c'est par exemple de ne
pas refuser impatience c'est de
euh toujours pratiquer le soin
nécessaire bon donc on ne voit pas ce
que ces prescriptions déontologiques ont
à voir avec un contrat entre un
organisme complémentaire et un adhérent
et donc votre amendement introduit plus
de de flou juridique et d'incertitude
qu'il ne résout euh le problème si tel
est votre préoccupation de la juste
information euh de l'adhérent qui elle
est un enjeu évidemment tout à fait
important le principe de la bonne
information du de l'adhérent est fixé
dans le cadre des principes généraux qui
doivent s'appliquer à ces réseaux et
c'est ce que j'ai indiqué tout à l'heure
à l'occasion de mon intervention
liminaire cette information elle doit
être délivrée avant la conclusion du
contrat et tout au long de l'exécution
de ce contrat merci madame la ministre
madame procacia vous avez la parole et
je crois non je ne le retire pas je
crois simplement parce que il y a cette
ambigué que nous évoquons depuis le
début et en particulier parce qu'il y a
une profession médicale qui est un ordre
et c'est l'ordre des chirurgiens
dentistes qui est mélangé avec des
professions commerciales qui sont les
opticiens qui sont les audioprothésistes
or les ordres ont des règles
déontologiques et vouloir iler les
chirurgiens dentistes uniquement par le
biais de ces réseaux les assimiler à des
commerçants qui vont ne faire que de la
prothèse alors qu'ils ont un rôle
important vous le savez madame la
ministre en matière de
conservation des soins de prévention de
la santé c'est vouloir impliquer que les
chirurgiens dentistes qui seront dans
les
réseaux ne sont là que pour faire de la
prothèse alors qu'ils ont un rôle
essentiel de prévention et de soins ce
qui n'est pas le cas des autres réseaux
voilà l'esprit de cet amendement c'est
la raison pour laquelle je le maintiens
merci je vais mettre au voie
l'amendement 15 rectifié qui a reçu deux
avis défavorables qui est pour son
adoption qui est contre abstention il
n'est pas adopté amendement 16 rectifier
madame procassia vous avez la
parole alors par cet amendement il
s'agit garantir euh la sanction des
clauses qui sont présentes dans les
conventions euh notamment cell des
réseaux qui fonctionnent sans base
réglementaire ou législative et faire en
sorte que toutes ces dispositions
euh soi les clauses contraires soit des
clauses oh excusez-moi les clauses
contraires aux dispositions de l'article
l8638 qui sont réputés non écrit Merci
avis de la commission sur cet amendement
16 rectifiés merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
cet amendement prévoit que les clauses
contraires aux dispositions de l'article
2 sont réputé non écrite une clause
réputée non écrite est une clause
contraire au aux dispositions expresse
de la loi dire de ces clauses qu'elles
sont non écrites revientent à dire
qu'elles sont censé n'avoir jamais
exister il s'agit d'un point juridique
spécifique au droit des contrats dans le
nouvel article
l8638 nous posons des principes
fondamentaux qui ne ressemblent pas
nécessairement à ce que l'on trouve
habituellement en droit de la
consommation ou de l'habitation ces
principes ne sont pas tous aussi précis
qu'une clause contractuelle de ce fait
je ne suis pas certain que l'expression
réputée non écrite soit judicieuse pour
l'ensemble de l'article
l8638 c'est pourquoi donc j'exprime une
réserve quant à la rédaction de
l'amendement plus que sur le fond et
comme la Commission est un peu fatigué
en fin d'après-midi elle s'en remet à
nouveau à l'avis du Gouvernement merci
votre avis madame la ministre avis des
favorable monsieur le Président à dire
vrai si des les clauses d'un réseau étai
contraire à ce qui est précisé dans la
loi elle serait par définition sans
fondement juridique et contestable
devant un juge donc dire qu'elles sont
Nules et non avenu n'a pas de
conséquence si l'adhérant ne les
conteste pas il si une clause est
contraire à ce qui est écrit dans la loi
la clause est évidemment illégale et
elle est annulable merci Madame
procacia il est maintenu vous le retirez
il est maintenu je mets au voix
l'amendement 16 rectifié qui a reçu deux
avis défavorables qui est pour son
adoption qui est contre abstention il
n'est pas adopté je vais mettre au voix
l'article 2 qui est pour son
adoption qui est contre abstention
l'article 2 est adopté nous en arrivons
à l'article 3 avec un amendement numéro
7 présenté par Madame procacia et bien
nous ne remettons pas en cause le
rapport mais on souhaiterait que la
période de 3 ans soit
supprimée avis de la commission qui a
retrouvé force et vigueur
voil
merci monsieur le
Président Madame le ministre mes chers
collègues ça va très bien cet amendement
concerne l'article 3 de la proposition
de loi relatif au rapport demandé au
gouvernement il supprime la durée de 3
ans qui étit prévu par l'Assemblée
nationale je soulingne que notre
collègue alinar chimbaau avait posé
cette même question la semaine dernière
et j'avais indiqué qu'il est de rénavant
d'usage dans un souci de simplification
du droit de ne plus adopter de rapports
éternels qui de fait en dcétude mais qui
sont toujours inscrits dans une loi
c'est Monsieur marsman ancien président
de la commission des lois de l'Assemblée
qui avait fait adopter ce principe dans
une loi de simplification pour autant il
ne s'agit que d'un usage nouveau qui
connaî déjà certaines exceptions et pour
bien indiquer que nous avons passé
l'après-midi à travailler très
sérieusement ici dans une instance qui
s'appelle le Sénat le dernier avis sera
un avis de
sagesse merci monsieur monsieur le
rapporteur général madame la
ministre écoutez monsieur le
présidentame madame la députée madame la
sénatrice pardon euh je dois dire que la
sagesse est toujours recommandé le
gouvernement a plutôt envie de vous
donner un avis défavorable parce que
nous ne pouvons pas d'un côté nous ne
pouvons pas d'un côté réclamer la
simplification et de l'autre multiplier
les les tâches qui viennent complexifier
et alourdir le travail administratif euh
voilà al que il est facile de demander
un rapport je voudrais vous rappeler que
ce sont les services ministériels qui
rédigent ces rapports vous demander que
les fonctionnaires soient en nombre plus
limité
que on ne peut pas en permanence
alourdir la charge de travail de
personnes à qui on demande de se
recentrer sur l'essentiel de leur
mission donc je vous dis moi je donne un
avis de sagesse mais en indiquant que à
force de vouloir demander à demander
trop de rapports on s'expose au fait que
ces rapports ne soient pas remis en
temps et en heure ou ne soi pas remis du
tout et je dois dire d'ailleurs que
j'aurais préféré qu'on demande pas un
rapport annuel immédiatement he mais bon
cela c'est escrit dans proposition de
loi parce qu'il faut donner le temps au
rapport au réseau de se mettre en œuvre
pour qu'on puisse apprécier et faire des
rapports évaluation qui est une portée
significative pour que les les
éclairages qui vous seront apportés est
un sens donc vous avez entendu mon appel
à la sagesse et chacun comprendra ce
qu'il veut par la sagesse que je lui
demande don je lui demande de faire
preuve mais en tout cas je vous remercie
merci Madame la Ministre donc un avis
sagement défavorable ou de sagesse
défavorablement et l'AVE de sagesse de
la Commission pour explication de vote
madame Alquier vous avez la parole ah
pas sur l'amendement alors je mets au
voie l'amendement numéro 7 qui est pour
son son
adoption qui est
contre l'amendement numéro 7 n'est pas
adopté je vais mettre au voix l'article
3 explication de vote oui oui pour
explication de vote madame
Alquier
sur nous sommes sur l'article
3 alors Monsieur valerenberg sur
l'article 3 explication de vote oui je
regrette que on n pas adopté cet
amendement parce que je crois qu'il est
important d'évaluer j'ai j'ai bien
compris que ce texte était un texte
d'encadrement législatif de pratique
déjà autorisé mais peu vraiment cerné et
je crois qu'il est
important que nous mesurions les effets
en quelque sorte de la législation que
nous mettons en place sur les
conséquences moi moi je je trouve que il
faut pas voter ça allègrement on voit
bien les marges d'erreur qui
existent les marges d'erreur qui
existent et donc cette évaluation me
paraît nécessaire bon vous voulez pas
que ça soit chaque année mais pour une
période de 3 ans c'est pas très clair
d'ailleurs chaque année pour une période
de 3 ans
euh hein ça peut être diff différemment
interprété ce que je souhaiterais c'est
que cette évaluation euh comporte le
maximum de critères alors il est prévu
là porte notamment sur les garanties et
prestations que les conventions
comportent très bien leur conséquences
pour les patients essentielles en
particulier en terme d'accès aux soins
et là on revient à ce que nous disions
tout à l'heure sur l'article 2 d'accès
aux soins de la proximité
notamment on pourrait peut-être
l'ajouter et mais c'est plus c'est plus
l'heure et et de reste à charge et leur
impact sur les tarifs est pris patiqués
par les professionnels vous voyez qu'il
y a beaucoup de questions et beaucoup de
critères qui sont là évoqués et dont il
m'est il nous paraît important de
connaître les résultats le plus
rapidement possible alors euh on votera
bien sûr l'article 3 parce qu'il me
paraît essentiel pour le texte mais
madame la ministre ne croyez pas que ce
soit une
surcharge qui c'est une nécessité si on
veut pas que ça soit la jungle dans le
système de remboursement modulé qu'on va
mettre en place merci mon cher collègue
je mets au voix l'article 3 qui est pour
son
adoption contre
abstention l'article 3 est adopté je
vais mettre au voix l'ensemble de la
proposition de loi y a-t-il des demandes
d'explication de vote alors madame
Alquier je vous en
prie vous avez la
parole l'accès au soins est une priorité
de la politique de santé du gouvernement
et de la majorité qui le soutient si
cette proposition de loi ne peut suffire
à elle seul à résoudre les difficultés
d'accès aux soins elle en constitue né
moins une des réponses je l'ai dit dans
mon intervention générale beaucoup ici
l'ont redit il y avait urgence à
légisférer et trois familles et
d'organismes complémentaires devant être
mises sur le pied d'égalité il y a
d'autant plus urgence aujourd'hui où
l'objectif d'une généralisation des
complémentaires de santé de qualité a
été réaffirmé par le Président de la
République et où la concurrence entre
organism et viv mais au-delà de cette
urgence et de cette inconcruté cette
propos i de loi a le mérite de procéder
à un toilettage du système et à mieux
encadrer les conventions de trous les
organismes complémentaires et certains
professionnels de santé ce vide
juridique qu'il faut aujourd'hui combler
nous donne l'occasion de Revo voilà vous
avez pu suivre la proposition de loi
socialiste sur les réseaux de soins
mutualistes un texte qui vise à mieux
rembourser les personnes qui s'adressent
à des spécialistes référencés dans
certains réseaux de mutuel tout de suite
la suite de nos programmes sur public
enat intervention en Somalie présence en
Afghanistan ou au mali jamais sans doute
les services secrets français n'ont été
autant sollicités alors qui sont-ils qui
sont les hommes ou les femmes qui les
composent comment sont-ils recrutés
sélectionnés formés encadrés motivés et
bien c'est ce qu'on va voir dans le
débat de la semaine sur Public Sénat
avec d'abord le portrait d'une légende
un véritable mythe dans le monde du
renseignement il s'appelle Robert
Maloubier et le film s'appelle l'espion
qui vous salue
bien le débat présenté par Benoît du Ken
samedi à 23h sur publ
Sénat alors cher priant Jacob vous
auriez pu être plus franc et faire comme
dans les cours d'école me traiter de péd
voilà c'est un jure qui fait tant de mal
notamment aux jeun qui découvr le
sexualité je tiens à vous rassurer cher
pr Jacob j'assume j'en suis fier malgré
une longue tradition de bronca et de
prise de bec on est parfois surpris par
certaines répliques entendues sur les
bancs de l'Assemblée alors s'agit-il
d'une question de